[Music]
so
[Music]
come on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
come on
[Music]
[Music]
there's
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
three two one
[Music]
three two one
[Music]
bruh
[Music]
come on
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
get out take it out
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
i feel like it's too obvious to take
queen here but i feel like that's the
right move
oh okay check first then take queen
brother i'm looking at all my [ __ ]
pieces connect what about it
that's not it [ __ ] are you guys stupid
oh no dude
i need i need caffeine give me a second
hold up
i said [ __ ] are you stupid
closed captioning
our match will start in about two
minutes i think
so you know what i gotta play our song
[Music]
i'm ready to get shivers baby
oh let's go
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
welcome to blog champs three our first
match of the day
going down in two minutes versus mick
the fortnite gamer and nico lol
the hunter thief content creator tick
tocker
here we go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all right
sorry ladies and gentlemen it seems like
we have a technical difficulty it is 12
o'clock and the match has not begun
please hold on tight maybe go grab a
snack get a drink now's a great time to
maybe go use the bathroom
as you figure out what's happening uh
production
[Music]
he's filming a tick tock she's gonna be
late i got the shooters
what the [ __ ] okay
welcome everyone to poc champs three
presented by grip6 and
i have finally as you can see managed to
replace gotham chat
by a much better commentator big brain
lady thank you so much for joining us
cutie cinderella hi i'm excited to be
here
don't tell levy i took his spot he
doesn't know
i think he will not notice he had to go
to the dentist
so we are filling in but i think your
sense of humor is much better and your
chest moves too
will definitely demonstrate that you are
in the right place box jumps to
participant cutie cinderella
here to commentate on some of the big
clashes of today including the second
match
that will involve ludwig cutie
your thoughts on that upcoming match
that we announced
as the battle for your heart because
code miko said that
maybe if she beats ludwig she could be
perhaps your future date true miko has
had a crush on me for a very long time
uh i've tried everything to keep her
away from me but
i i did have to agree to that so whoever
wins that will get
dinner with me the stakes are high let's
take a look at the format of the
tournament
park term three the players are split
into four groups
we are still in the group stage the
final clashes of the group stage
there's a double round robin with 10
minutes and the five second
increments per move a win in the match
is three points
in case it's a time we're gonna go to an
armageddon
and two points for the winner 1.4 the
one losing the armageddon match
afterwards the knockout stage will begin
that's coming out
in a few days and a big reminder of
course on the big prices they have
some amazing prices here for the group
stage as well as for the championship
bracket and a consolation
bracket and also the fact that many of
the players have
already offered their prices in advance
to
charity we have a community outreach
throughout the tournament chess.com is
going to match donations up to a hundred
thousand dollars you can use the comment
exclamation mark charity
in the chat click on the link in order
to donate and chess.com will match your
donations
as well as the participants prices are
matched
by chess.com and all go to the 16
charities chosen by the participants
here are some of the charities chosen
cutie
did you have any word in which charity
ludwig was going to donate to
no he he's a big fan of no kid hungry
he's done a lot of stuff with them
he is often hungry so he just wants to
help
anybody who could be hungry that's a
great cause to support
yeah we really appreciate all these
amazing creators streamers gamers actors
to come together for such a good cause
and also to show us
our amazing their amazing chess moves
let's see how the standings are looking
so far in group
a star dosh and benji fishy are
both on six points and cutie today they
are facing
each other how do you see that match
going down today
i think benji is scary i'm scared i've
never been more afraid of a fortnight
kid
um and i am often afraid of fortnite
kids and
uh seems scary he's so good he is so
good
and he's like training behind the scenes
and he's been he's been training for
like a month
and that's very impressive in group d we
have ludwig on
three points who is playing today
against code miko so if ludwig wins he
will catch moist critical in the first
place is there a big rivalry between
charlie and ludwig
i think um i think it's this weird like
big brother complex like ludwig has
always had a little bit of a crush on
charlie
and so i guess that's not what you do
with your big brother typically people
don't have crushes on their big brother
i guess we're all different
but anyway i think it'd be good
if he beat him i think that's all he's
looking for he would like to beat him he
would like to
you know prove that he is better at
chess at least than charlie
makes perfect sense and that's what nico
said during her interview that
today is going to be a fight between 100
thieves and tsm
nico facing myth these are our upcoming
clashes if we bring up the starting
times
we are starting the first match a bit
later because we had to
jump in instead of mr gotham chess
um and hikaru we are filling big boots
here cutie but i think you are ready for
the challenge i'm not sure if i am
i think it'll be easy i think um you
know i think i'm just
as good as hikaru and you're just as
funny as levi so it should be
should be the same thing thank you yeah
no one will notice we are not the same
people that they were promised
that they were on screen so we are just
moments away
from the first game between nico and
myth
i wonder if we already have nico with us
we were watching the stream of
myth earlier he's got some banger music
there as his preparation
i am a little confused where um i
usually you know when i show up to these
chess events i usually have my women gm
title i'm a little
confused where is that yeah i'm just
exactly i
i thought i earned it you know of course
yeah i think it's a it's just a typo on
the layout because they thought that was
levi's spot and he's clearly
yeah that makes sense that makes sense
and to everyone
um don't worry i'm here to represent
those of us who just
can't seem to get better at chess that's
not true lady you have improved so much
i
i always say whenever i talk about cutie
you were one of the most
impressive participants when it came to
pogchamps too because you started out
as someone who only knew how to pieces
move then you took a couple of lessons
you started the puzzle ground you kept
on playing also in your spare time
and you improved so much from match to
match you were really one of those
participants that made the biggest
progress from one match to the next one
and it's only a few days in between
matches
oh well you're nice i think uh i think
if you look at these two there's there's
a slight difference in
energy i've noticed
i've noticed already i'm curious to see
if this will affect their gameplay just
looking at them
i think nico is missing waking up
i wonder she'll be streaming too i don't
see her
live yet so maybe today she will skip
streaming
i don't know if you heard cutie but she
basically took one of the last
flights out of texas she had no power
no clean water and that was their
condition for
a couple of days oh we have the first
moves on the board i think if we refresh
the board hopefully it will show oh
if we click on the list there we go
there we go there we go
mika playing with the white pieces in
this first game and she has a very
unique
opening i don't know if you have heard
of this opening cutie it's called the
bird's opening when you push the f-pawn
at the very start to f4 she's playing so
we're playing fast
holy moly
they're both playing fast they're both
over the 10-minute mark
exactly i feel like nico always plays
this fast she
she said in one of the interviews that
she's impatient
i understand that needs to make a move
and move and move
well i wonder about miss uh why is she
not taking a bit longer
oh interesting that pawn is
just no it's not well we're going to get
used to me calling things incorrectly
nova is because that's what many of the
viewers will be looking at and it's a
great question
is the e3 pawn hanging at the moment not
because it's guarded by the c1 bishop
but it's a great setup for myth he's the
one with less experience
here nico has played more games than
anyone almost in the field
and miss only started playing chess
recently he finds another strong move
knight to d5 attacking the pawn on e3
that you are looking at
let's listen in if we can hear his
thought process or he's just very
focused
oh that's silent for me for now
yes i don't know if he has music or if
he's just talking or
i i i mean talking in his head he says
clearly not talking
he is not talking i know that brain
cells are talking to each other
yes so we we normally have a myth
with some vibe background music
amazing beats but today he went on
full silence not talking extremely
focused
drops the bishop back to d6 his piece
setup
is looking nice but some of the pieces
are unprotected the d5 knight
and the f5 bishop are unprotected and
nico is trying to take advantage of it
oh
he said a word
dark we can just guess it means
we can just guess we can yeah we can
guess his words i think he said
cereal and he's just really hungry and
he knew if he ate today he'd be fine
i understand myth we're all with you it
could be it could be the kids
cookies coming up next knight to c3 good
move by nico developing the knight and
they keep playing really fast jazz rook
28 is another good move
um i wonder though if nico will find a
way to
attack the f5 bishop and so she does it
the knight jumps but it's the rook
that is attacking the bishop on f5
will miss see it do you think that he
notices that even though it's a night
move
the bishop too is in danger because of
the rook of nico
i think i don't think he'll realize i
don't think he'll realize
i think he is going to move the knight
yep just like that
about to take on e5 which is all right
for
now since he has captured a piece but
but if he uses
yeah if he moves that rook then oh well
she's good she can take
i don't mind that oh she missed it
i think oh yes sorry i was seeing it uh
with a bit of a time difference
uh she hasn't noticed yet that the
bishop on f5
is hanging the rook could take it she's
attacking the the rook on a8 but now if
the rook moves
that will attack the bishop on b7
i don't know queen trade or not myth
what do you think
he moves the rook that's a good move now
both bishops are hanging
and queen trade we love one of those
mm-hmm
why
oh interesting oh no nico
didn't spot the hanging it's gonna be
it's gonna be
[Music]
bishop to d4 check by myth is a really
strong move because
now he could take the bishop of nico for
free
yes check me
checkmate uh maybe not jackman just yet
but the bishop the bishop is hanging
the bishop of nico was dead but now he
says
the realization that two of which is
regarding this
he had no clue now i wonder
would it be a good move to bring the
bishop on f4
up to c7 and do a little bit of us is
that a fork
absolutely two rocks a great move cutie
you are right that the bishop could
capture the pawn and attack both rooks i
wonder if niko will spot it after
a potential trade on e4 myth could take
the bishop on e4 or try to take on c3 as
well there's still
quite many options for him as well to
try to take things up
no i should have just taken that from
there
oh okay so he stops that
he did stop it and is attacking the e4
bishop navi two of his pieces as well as
the bishop on d4 could capture on c3 so
oh nico didn't see that it's not enough
to bring the rook in
because there's a thing called remove
the defender that if
myth realizes that his bishop can
capture the knight
then the e4 bishop will not have enough
defending pieces
do you think do you think that's
something that myth will see right now
i don't think he will it's quite
complex because you you need to first
discover that
as of now the bishop on e4 is fine but
the only reason why it's fine is because
the knight is
is helping he didn't see it
um but even like this his move to
is quite a tricky one he captures that
pawn
which was defending the knight and if
the knight moves away the bishop is
still in trouble
this is still challenging nico made a
move that hangs the bishop on e4
but now we'll miss i think see
it i think nico's goal is really just to
get that c7 pawn
i don't know i don't know where else
she's going with that uh oh yeah the
bishop is
gone now so it's equal material from a
piece up now
myth has taken the bishop and is up upon
threatening knight to f to check
among other options this was a great
move by myth because he also could have
captured the bishop with the rook
but then the rook would have been in
trouble after knight takes night
i don't know if we can show that
position for a moment uh
cute if you go back one move before myth
took on
e4 let me know yes so if rook takes
bishop if the black rook takes the
the bishop on e4 there's an intermediate
move for white knight nightclubster
knight captures knight and that
undermines the defense of the rook with
a check
that's lovely look at that he didn't
fall for it he took the
light on e4 he didn't fall for this and
now the game is wide open it could be
anyone's game oh
no i do this all the time we want to
recap anyway i think it i think it was
good
this is what you missed you guys um
in case you were sad uh we're just going
to skip to where they are though
because you've seen it it's very cool
it's really cool
this is the current position and wait a
second
knight f6 no okay no oh we need to
uh oh go back do you see where the moves
are
so we are still in our analysis and
right there should be a button
for um that's like a refresh button
um there it is yes there we go
yeah great so
this is the current position and
nico has played bishop to e3 i wonder i
wonder if you click
refresh again will it show that she has
made one more move
um oh our board decided to give up
on us for a moment so we will refresh
yeah amazing here we go
this is now the current position thank
you cutie for helping me out there
bishop to e3 and bishop to e5 what do
you predict for this game that's been
wild roller coaster nico winning a piece
then myth winning it back a few moves
later
tactics here and there what would be
your prediction
i still see i still i hmm
i think nico's gonna take this in the
end but this is just a bit of a tricky
situation right now
it's very tricky nico definitely has a
lot more experience than myth as we were
pointing out
she played more games than most
participants combined
she has been playing chess for years
already
before it was even cool she's the og
actually she
didn't know that i didn't know that how
long has she been playing like when did
she start chess did she have she ever
said
i think her chess.com account was
created back in 2018 or
wow
yeah she discovered chess before before
it was cool to play
auto updating for us really
um bishop to a yeah bishop takes a7 i
think we are up to date
okay we're good i hope it will keep yeah
it keeps okay
moves finally we have reached a stage
where
both players started spending a bit more
time the opening
phase was an absolute bullet game where
both of them were blitzing out the moves
now method is down to five minutes
nico's still
on seven and a half and now after
capturing the pawn on a7 she has a past
pawn that a3 pawn
could be a potential queen but it's
still offer
oh from promotion the evaluation bar has
jumped but i don't think this is obvious
what
what's going on um the knight
is now on a square that is disconnecting
the black bishop from from that point
true ever since you mentioned that she
had that bishop of capture with the
rooks hanging i think she has seen it
too
now this is tough for myth because
suddenly
he is down upon he was up upon and he
had the past two moves
he lost two pawns he's gotta move this
rook now
where do you think he will move and
there aren't too many good fighters
right above
right above well he forgets that that
rook was guarding the bishop on e5
and yeah takes it nico
excellent that was an interesting
gesture there by nico now myth could
take the knight on c7 and it's not
background checkmate because of the
knight on d6
it could look like it's checkmate and i
wonder if if nico
will try to give checkmate you are
nico's coach right
yes yeah one of her coaches the butter
sisters
and me you know what happens if she
loses hannah
it's your fault that's how it works
that's what happens
if she loses it's all the coach's fault
every time
well i hope she keeps going strong in
that case i hope she keeps going from
bishop c5 i love it attacks the knight
on d6 so she's now again
up a piece but knight takes c4 now the
c7 knight is hanging under
she trades there we go that's a great
movie
i hope he does because if he just moves
the king the rook will be captured for
free so miss
shouldn't give up more material
it takes he could have just gone down
and taken that night
correct you should have taken it before
yes you had that opportunity that was a
missed opportunity
this should be now simple to convert
if it wasn't for that knight only being
a bit lost and bit apart from the rest
of the crew knight to d2
attacking the rook oh that's that's a
nice one because nico is pinning the
knight so it it cannot go wherever it
wants to the rook on b2 would be hanging
four minutes left for miss and seven
minutes for nico
she's amazing at time yeah she's very
fast
really a speedy player i think she's one
of the few who will not have an issue to
adjust to a tiebreaker when it comes to
armageddon
or the blitz tiebreaker in the knockout
stage
what was it like for you cutie the time
control
you played the previous event that i
think was still 15 minutes
the starting time but some of the
tiebreakers
would be blitz or armageddon did you
find it difficult to adjust to
rapid and blitz no i liked it i liked
i liked going fast i think chess is a
hard game because you have to be
insanely patient
um oh we see a night fork
there there could be options with the
knight um at the same time niko is
pushing the passport i think that's a
very good practical decision in
end games pawns become even more
valuable a lot more valuable than
how they are actually in the beginning
of the game because you can
push them to the end of the board and
that's what she's doing she literally is
just pushing it all the way
marching toward the background to
promote
can me should be easy for her i don't
think
um i mean he could just move his
rook over right and just get rid of
get rid of the pawn yes you are right
then lose his
knight excellent yeah the thought
process
that the right one that's exactly the
right one because you need to try to
stop the pawn with the rook
but then the knight will be in trouble
so that's why this
rook move by nico earlier pinning the
knight was a great decision
and i think she knows it that now her
position oh
miss is attacking both the rook and the
bishop but the rook on b2
was unprotected now it's a full rook up
for nico
oh poor myth um he fought very well but
eventually the experience of nico
has decided i think some of the most
critical moments when everything
was hanging nico kept her cool and
calculated better
and i am i'm gonna take uh everyone's
mad at me because i pointed out that
fork from chat but i am gonna listen to
chat because i'm here to represent chat
so if i look stupid it's because you
guys look stupider
and yeah i just use stupider and i know
that's not a word
but i want to look as dumb as you guys
okay and that's the goal here
it's embarrassing isn't it yeah
sorry to hear it okay so looking at this
nico still has seven whole minutes
i don't understand how she's so fast
is anna
great perfect this is
this is awesome um
anna looks lovely and i'm totally cut
out for this
and you guys are enjoying yourselves and
we're having a good time and nico is
gonna take this w she's just gonna
laddermate
any second now
myth is gonna fight it at this point
this is when everyone in chat spams very
toxically and they tell you to resign
but nico's got it that feels good
and myth myth is taking his loss well
it looks like he's gonna review the game
and we're just gonna take a quick break
before the next
match
[Applause]
though yeah
really careful of that team there we're
gonna be like blow to this team on pool
though
let's get just bounce it
i think just bounce to the right yeah
yeah oh there's the floor
i think i bought my gun yeah just go
underneath
it here
maybe i'll keep one down if you want to
get refreshed
uh
yes
from your box and then
we could bounce right and we could go we
can go above this we can go like
but like we can go i mean yeah we could
land i don't know just keep going
i don't know i don't know though
okay i'll just follow you just do
whatever
might be able to drop down like all the
way over here like with one bouncer
yeah i thought i was saying i could mean
by that though yeah
you might get hard beamed actually
yeah yeah yeah
uh
dead
they're gonna target me
and we are back hey cutie how's it going
good
nothing has changed you saved chess from
their worst nightmare which was me
representing them alone
so happy to have you here i'm gonna be
honest i watch you on chess tv all the
time and you're fantastic so i don't
think it's so nice
there's no saving needed
[Laughter]
just all of the chat's hair they're just
pulling it out well hopefully we don't
got any mulders now
i'm here i'm happy to be here kitty
you're doing an excellent job so
i think that they were in good hands
regardless oh good oh good
well i'm excited to see this match nico
won the first match with a very cool
ladder mate
after promoting a pawn and um
myth is in good spirits myth is a very
competitive person so i do think
an l hurts his soul but he'll never
admit that because he's an optimist
[Laughter]
have liked to listen ends with him and
just hearing him cheer himself on
but you know you lose a game how do you
turn it around like this because it's no
fun to
you know struggle in any match but how
do you pump yourself up
you know i have a feeling that
myth's best move here is just
to have fun because i don't think he's
going to win
and so he might as well have fun taking
the l
wow i have no faith okay
well i mean some people in the past
during public gyms have taken a shot
some liquid courage right we've seen
that happen would you know anything
about that
yes yes yes i'm a heavy drinker
especially before 5 p.m
whoa i wasn't trying to call anybody out
here i'm just saying that some people
you know
they just go within that actually could
improve their chess yeah i think
maybe he could try that i just think the
great thing about myth
is he look at him he's still smiling
yeah
and he's watching a chess video that's
totally relevant
to what chess and fortnite
what's that board it's cool whatever it
is
i don't want one probably really
expensive
this should help him though i think it's
a fortnight themed
chessboard he seems mesmerized
yeah we'll get him one of those he
honestly just seems happy
yeah he's a good loser he he's
just he's happy even when he loses and i
think that's admirable because i cry
when i lose
actually that's not yeah i won't play
chess with ludwig
because i'm a bad loser but he's a bad
winner
that surprises nobody yeah
and well i guess we do have the game i
don't know if myth knows that we have
the game he's kind of just chillaxin
myth's board doesn't seem to be loading
um
hopefully uh he refreshes soon
his clock is running and
nico just seemed bored like hey uh myth
you want to get this one on the road
oh the game's cancelled we'll get it up
and running
oh gosh i do wish i went into games like
that
just chilled just chill just hanging
back
i mean he seems as relaxed as he gets
and just to remind everybody that
and while we still have one more game
here we do have two more fun matches
we've got ludwig taking on code miko
benji fishy against
sardosh so cutie any favorites in the
other two matchups
i sh i can't speak on ludwig or code
miko because
one of them will hate me if i choose any
bias they are both very important to me
um and then benji and sard
what's his i'm so sorry ludwig just
calls him sardoush and i don't know his
real name all i can think of is sardoush
sargosh sounds right
yes i am so he just goes around the
house and he's like can't wait to play
sardine and i'm like you've got to stop
talking like that but sorry dosh i think
sardosh and benji are both really really
good but i'm
personally afraid of fortnite kids so
okay
i you know i don't know about how scary
they are but their chest has been great
those two and
well we do have central control by myth
and nico moving quickly she typically
does so
she plays really fast she does and i i
wonder
she said before like sometimes she just
feels like she needs to move and that
helps her chest
she's gained a lot of rating throughout
this pog champs she's up to 8.72 she
started i think
in the 500s yeah when i saw how low she
was i was like wow nico sucks
but then you know she's gotten so good
that now i'm afraid of her
and i'm a big nico stan okay i do the
hey boomer dance every morning and send
it to her she doesn't reply
did you coach her as well because i know
that you have a coaching pedigree
i did some coaching with pokemane and
then i retired
i guess you know can't uh climb any
higher than that
yeah okay one time thing and while here
nico plays b6 she's going for another
fianchetto
and cutie do you see this often in your
games or is it pretty rare
uh this happens a lot um i never see it
personally i just lose my pieces but it
does happen a lot
well nico is going for an aggressive
plan with c5 striking the center
and the engine bar just jumped up here
and it's because
white can continue taking space with a
pawn push to e5
but it's very natural that myth would
take the pawn i think that's our
first instinct okay pawn has been taken
by myth
and now that bar drops but it's so
tricky because
when you're playing you obviously don't
have the bar and even while watching it
may not be clear
but a large reason why is bishop on e3
normal developing move
this knight can come to g4 and this
bishop on g7
is the best piece on the board
i just think it's fascinating how far
ahead you can think because as you're
talking i'm barely catching
up chess minds are insane can we all
agree
um no i mean you know they're okay and
that also you're learning a lot
i have watched your streams i don't know
if i should admit that but i've watched
your streams you know you
you're doing great you are learning and
last night for example i saw you playing
you were beating up on some peeps and
you told a great story i got to say that
was a fantastic story
the one i peed in a cup that was the
story yeah
long story chat sometimes you have to
pee in a cup
um i think uh i got up to 900 rating
and then i got a lesson from donya and i
fell back down to 800. i don't know
whose fault it is but it's not mine
you know donya is a good guy a great
coach
i think he will take the blame as any
good coach should yeah i do think you
are
learning things and well nico she's
striking here with a5 she's pushing all
of her pieces forward
and i don't think that myth has a plan
so actually when you when you look at
this position
what are some ideas that you can see
here i mean if i were myth i would start
moving my knights his knights need to
get out there playing somehow
am i crazy no no but he just
lost his bishop for a pawn there he oh
took there and
the bishop was captured so i think he's
really sad for him i thought it was free
and ended up not being the case
oh wow sorry i have a
rodent in my room making some noise now
the thing about my cat is my cat is a
big myth fan
whenever i want this is not a joke
whenever i watch myth
nobody else i'll watch myth's stream and
the cat will come over and just sit and
watch
so he's probably really upset that i'm
rooting for nico today but he loves myth
and cats are not always forgiving so i
hope that you don't get scratched too
hard later
no i think he'll be okay
well i hope so and for miss you know he
hopes that his position will be okay
because he dropped a piece for just a
pawn
and the position still looks solid for
white but i like what nico's doing she's
ahead
so she's trying to trade and if she can
just develop her pieces naturally try to
go on the b file because that's a pawn
on b2
that can be under attack it's hard to
see how white
on the other hand means some attacking
chances
i think yeah i think oh that was oh
apparently not a good move i thought
that was a great move by miss
apparently not the b4 square
not very well defended but also nico has
more time than she started with
nico's amazing with time it blows my
mind
i mean she's just too fast and
she honestly maybe there should be a
bullet tournament with all you getting
one minute on the clock
i think she could win it i'm curious if
she's ever tried bull
i'd love to see her her bullet games
um judging by how she plays in during
this podcast i think she'd be pretty
good
she's playing well she's playing fast
confidently and now she's up a piece
and myth is trying to figure out what to
do how to push forward he looks so
concentrated
he's a gamer he's a gamer by nature
i think myth should work on his
intimidation tactics he looks too nice
[Laughter]
so what would he have to do i think he
should um you know i think he should
call nico some names
i think he should tweet at her and he
should be like bye boomer i think that's
what he should do
and maybe it'll mess her up and she'll
lose
is it that simple buy boomer and then
well i've tried doing stuff like that
it's never worked
but maybe for her maybe for her
and if mitt did turn on that like mean
streak i don't even know if it's
possible like
i feel like no one would believe it so
no
yeah no one would believe it i did have
a lesson with anna where i taught anna
um how to talk [ __ ] and it was
hilarious um sweet anna
being mean to chess players is not
something you've seen often but
it was awesome it was great uh well i
think we could all learn a thing or two
from not just
about being mean to other people but uh
you know in many other regards including
chess you are making progress here so
black is still up a piece this king on
g1 is in trouble
how do you think that black should
continue this game
i think um i think that bishop needs to
get out of there it's all tucked in
that's all i think about again i'm here
to represent
the normal people in chat not the
brilliant people in chat
but all i can think about is normal no
you're not normal
wow that hurts your brain is massive
okay
and it's not fair to the rest of us that
are subpar at everything thought we're
getting along real well but not
normal so i'm still angry about it oh my
gosh
oh oh okay
so using your idea though to get the
bishop out but
could drop in 94. yeah i think we're
just going to lose that knight
well that's just a trade i suppose
correct well
a pawn was taken and oh the engine did
not like that move so the big issue
and she just took a knight on c3 is that
this king
has been out in the open so actually
just a move ago queen out to b6
check puts this king in a world of hurt
but knight 63 you can't complain about
that as
she took a piece and she still is up
material
hey
nice to be staring at the queen right
now
true where would you move that queen
i mean i would just i would just trade
if i was
oh he does it he goes queen c8 so she's
trying to trade
you're up uh a bishop and a pawn so that
makes sense just to liquidate
into a simpler position to win i think
we missed the big storyline is that
niko's under 10 minutes moving too
slowly
yeah nico's really got to work on her
time i thought she was doing well i take
it all back
yeah i think we're all disappointed in
her for the slow pace that she's moving
at
what in what world does myth come back
um
i don't know you tell me you've played
this term before how dare you
how dare you turn that back on me i was
just trying to scare you
ask a fantastic commentator her thoughts
on how a player can mount a comeback
that's all
i think he
myth could pay someone to get the power
turned off at nico's house
i think and then oh
oh no he goes no no i forgot texas i'm
so sorry
um i i just think i think
nico decides to blunder a queen that's
what you always hope for let's just
blend our queen
and he can come back okay the problem
with that though
is that she put a rook on d.a so she's
doing the great things just trying to
trade off the pieces
and a certain point white doesn't have
much remaining so there can't even be
some surprise tactics or like
hey you won't see that i'm hitting your
queen because the only pieces you have
remaining
hmm so he needs to he needs to get that
knight out there and try to do something
with that right that's the only thing
yeah unfortunately it's uh pretty stuck
in place it is really stuck
i hear a cat he's mad because miss is
losing i told you
he is he doesn't want to hang out in
here anymore i just
we'll see he'll come back i hope so and
well i think it's now time for nico to
go on the offensive because
this king is open you are up a bishop in
a pawn
oh okay okay i clearly have to let him
out i'm so sorry about him
no you're all good you're all good the
cat's meow strikes again
and honestly this show just got way
worse now i'm solo this hurts to watch
for everybody i'm sorry
cutie we'll be right back i hope i don't
want to be here too oh there she is
really fast you saved me i stream in a
closet so
you saved me why what happened i mean
oh wow look we got some rooks traded
we did but i was alone and that was
unacceptable oh
okay yeah great hmm
[Music]
moving maybe there's a world where
i like to live in um oh
he's in check yeah
yeah check here and you gotta go
somewhere so king f2
the problem is the king will never find
actual safety the knight can just
drop back and the queen will infiltrate
so i think knight d4
makes sense and then bring the queen in
to f3 and this king is in
big big big trouble oh he's going to
attack
attack the knight
so you think nico's gonna move her
knight what are the chances she doesn't
move the knight and she loses it
none zero nico's a queen
she knows this okay i mean you know her
better than i do and you're her big
supporter she brought a queen in
speaking of queen and she defended her
night there
that's that's my girl i knew it we
didn't have any problems with that
yeah so you're proving your worth as a
chess commentator right now
yeah i can predict
so what's next what's up now well
unfortunately i think myth's gonna get
mated
okay right am i missing something
no it seems like you're you're correct
but how
would black go about delivering that
checkmate this feels like an awful chess
lesson
hess i know you know
okay don't i know you know i'm genuine i
was asking a question
oh this was a good move love that oh
never mind
okay hmm myth is so focused i've never
seen myth this focus though
yeah he's locked in right now and he's
trying to figure out how can he save
this game
and hovering on that queen
back to the night going from peace to
peace
this is just such a sad situation oh
this is interesting so maybe bringing
this down taking the night trading
queens
i think that's a smart move
yeah he that he's not interested in
i think you saw his knight is under
attack now he's hopping around
he's really concentrated yeah this is
safe though
okay so the queen's under attack so nico
has to see and she does that her queen's
enough to actually give
the check giving up her night to win
myths night so it's a fair trade night
for night and
with the extra material it seems like
nico is
you know pushing well on her path to
victory
for as far as nico is ahead i think myth
is holding on
yeah and you know i mean
she still needs to win the game right
and her bishop is pinned
it's the queen is very active for white
so he needs to
keep up the pressure and for nico she
needs to figure out a way to get that
bishop involved
imagine this just falls on time
okay she doesn't get the mate and myth
just runs out of time
that would be so sad for me why would it
be sad for you
it's just so it's not satisfying oh i
can't be the only one that thinks that
you need to check me is what you're
saying yeah yeah i agree i agree
and myth has three plus minutes so he
does have time to make his moves
and he doesn't have that many pieces
remaining so i guess at a certain point
he can shuffle and he needs to be
careful because now this pawn is under
attack
in addition to the check
he's been checked again yeah interesting
uh-huh and he moves king up so that was
really smart because if
this pawn had been captured uh let's say
you make this move and the pawn is
captured you also lose your
queen at the end of the line so he was
smart to
make the move that he did king up and
comes the queen
so is nico just gonna keep pinning
trying to get that queen
is that i think that's what she's gonna
try to do yeah she gave the check
she can just trade queens and then win
the end game
bring her king up and then moving her
pawns
in a in a world where how difficult is
just the bishop
a bishop king check is that something
that
nico is familiar with so there are
situations where the bishop
will not be enough so like we trade all
the pawns off and there's no only bishop
and king versus king that's a draw
so you need to be able to keep your
extra material
and there's some more nuanced things
here if black
only has this bishop and this pawn on h7
this actually is a draw of white just
puts the king in the corner but
unfortunately
well she could have taken the pawn f4
she's trading more
this could be a tricky situation
this just comes to as soon as she gets a
pawn promoted
that's gg that would be gigi exactly
and she needs to keep her f pawns and
she just bring her king up to the party
that's the thing it's an end game you
want your king under the arrow backwards
you want your king out up and going
and so she's going this way her king is
marching in and that's the last piece
needed
and she still has eight minutes on the
clock yeah
amazing she's too fast too strong
she is our queen i've said it i've said
it
so now yes she's yours she's yours too
we live in this state you and i the
state of chess.com and we decide who our
queen is and it is nico today
okay and by we decide you mean i decide
okay god i just want to make sure we
didn't even say in that yes
yes absolutely we're on the same page
chad has decided that you are their
queen though it seems
[Laughter]
oh i'm not deserving of such an honor i
voted for nico chad voted for hess
i guess hess will wear the crown today
he has a little more votes i suppose
oh well i guess we have to do a poll to
see what they really think right it's
the only way through
true true run the numbers
yeah we're data people here and it's
running
this pawn is running queen is happening
i think nico
has us under control the only question i
have is will she have more than 10
minutes when the game ends
i hope so
i'll be interested to see where did how
many matches is niko won this will be
her first
yes of your first match win that'll
awesome awesome awesome awesome but be
careful not to sail mate
okay the king has one move so it wasn't
stalemate
and now the king has some space but that
was actually pretty close she's making a
third queen
i hope so she's playing with her food
but be careful not to stalemate when you
have too many queens you could
accidentally allow your opponent
to get a stalemate
just making no mercy no mercy me nico
i almost said mikko uh oh freudian slip
wow
no one tell mika i'm thinking about her
it's okay she might shoot off into space
yeah mars oh
one is gone that was interesting
he said what there it is oh
there it is there's the finale two
nothing for nico and myth was just
absolutely startled by the queen can i
take that he probably shouldn't have
taken it would have given him better
stalemate chances yeah
that's a good point oh gosh well
2-0 score cutie was fun
and i guess we gotta go into a break so
we can bring the players on for an
interview
can't wait you sound stoked
i love talking to them that's my
favorite part okay well then
we might as well run there quickly and
leave uh ludwig for all the watch
like um like a nitro cold brew street
cream and i was like that's like 150
calories too many
i was like i'm just gonna get this black
coffee
with a bit oh jesus christ i'm gonna
test out okay chess.com
i'm telling a story about starbucks i'll
catch you up basically when i go to
starbucks
i like to get a drink without too many
calories because if you have liquid
calories you're just it's the easiest
way to gain weight
and i am so close to 200 pounds i'm at
199 pounds
if i if i hit 200 this game over i quit
streaming all right which
like 80 ubereats drivers who hate my
stream are going to [ __ ] bring me
free food but
seriously i don't want to hit 200 it's a
scary number so when i go to starbucks i
like to just get like a black coffee
with a little bit of milk
that's it that's all i get it's a simple
order and every time i get it all i say
is hey can i get a venti iced coffee
with some milk two percent milk and
they're like yeah yeah yeah for sure for
sure
go around get it and it's like it's like
it's weird to
describe but it's like it's like a good
drink
i'm like damn i i kind of [ __ ] with this
drink you know and
and i'm like i go to these other coffee
places the fancier ones in la and
i order the same thing and it always
tastes worse and i'm like huh
i don't know i just i really like the
milk they use cause the sweetness from
the milk
brings it out and one time i'm with my
roommate nick who's like a coffee savant
he's like a five head in coffee worked
at a barista place for like
four years and i'm like yeah man dude
you should try this coffee like the
sweetness from the milk makes it
delicious
and he tries it and he like recoils he's
like
oh he's like that's so sweet i'm like
yeah it's the milk
and he looks at me like the biggest
[ __ ] idiot
to land on planet earth and he's like
you think
that's the milk i'm like yeah that's the
milk yeah because i just order
yeah i order a venti iced coffee with a
bit of milk and the milk has a bit of
sugar if you don't know
he might not know this you know nick you
know milk a
little there's a little milk it has a
little sugar when it comes from the cow
teat
and so he looks at me and he's like
starbucks automatically puts
a pump of sugar syrup in every single
drink
if you don't ask for it
and so i tested this the next time i
asked for an iced coffee with
milk and a pump of syrup right because
that's what i like
i go around i pick it up the drink
is even [ __ ] sweeter
which i don't understand so there's like
two drinks
you can get in iced coffee with milk and
sugar and if you
ask for that you got an iced coffee with
milk in too much sugar
or you ask for an iced coffee with milk
and then you get an iced coffee with
milk and sugar
the perfect amount but you can't say
sugar because if you say sugar they give
you too much sugar
so you have to not say sugar to get a
pump
of sugar but if you say sugar you get
too many pumps of sugar
and now every time i go through the
drive-through i ask
for an iced coffee with milk but
sometimes then they don't put the sugar
in
anyways i'm having a very frustrating
experience going through
the starbucks drive-throughs trying to
get a simple drink
because i don't know how to ask for it
because if i ask for sugar it's too much
i got partner on twitch this morning i'm
so happy
thank you for being an inspiration to me
maybe someday i can be a content god
like you
hey man just give me 50 of all your
revenue and then we'll work together all
right
we'll go for the uh the rice gum deal
the rice come deal of a lifetime
appreciate the fiber though
uh anyway
and we're back joined by the players
nico first off congrats how does it feel
to score your first dub
um it feels good um i really
was feeling a little down because i was
like i really did lose
to little boy benji and then
a french dude named shasar dosh so i was
like
i need to get some kind of win and
luckily
myth was like hey i'm gonna let nico win
and i was like
nice a silver platter
on a silver platter here yeah
well cutie's cat was rooting for you
miss he is my cat oh my gosh really
would you say hi to my son please he's a
big fan of
this is a big fan of you i might have i
might i lost the battle but i won the
war because cutie's cat loved me
he loves your stream completely fine
he's the biggest myth simp
in the world let's go i have one finally
but i'm the biggest nico simp
so nice split household crazy
so she did great today yeah i mean nico
so you were playing really quickly did
you just we're feeling it today i mean
what was your mindset going in
uh taking on myth in this matchup i mean
i wasn't
i wasn't uh far from myths elo reading
like three weeks ago and then i just got
back into like grinding chess and i feel
like
i've already been playing for like over
a year so
i kind of already knew what the mindset
is at that elo
so i feel like i had like an advantage
there um
and and yeah so so i was i kind of
already was
in myth shoes not too long ago so i feel
like i already had like
an advantage in that sense she said
that elo how do you feel about that myth
that evo
dude i feel like i it wasn't even a
battle today then dude i
step into nico's world that's what
happened today exactly
dude is anybody here watching jutsu
kaizen she just
pulled you know she pulled out her realm
and engulfed me in it
that's what happened today i didn't know
what i was getting into
he's right that i knew the mental space
of that elo
and i came into assault and uh and take
advantage of it oh
yeah but i felt it i mean it's true i
mean it's a really good fight though
yeah and cutie was saying that if you
trash talks you think maybe it could
help your chest
i think you should have you know tweet
it out talk some [ __ ]
to nico tell her how bad a video game
she is
and she would have not even shown up
today at the same mental
that's true i was hoping for [ __ ] talk
man
i'm positive that would have cracked her
next time next time
yep indeed and well and
i guess the next match you guys both
that will be in the consolation bracket
how do you see your chances are you
thinking that far ahead or just uh happy
to
have this match under your belt and
what's your mindset like
i mean i i'm really i'm really ready to
take uh some more lessons
uh with anna and then the other anna
kramling
she plays also chess so i'm really
looking forward to that i wasn't able to
take
any lessons this week because of the
dallas storm so i
everything was out power was out
everywhere just flew out to california
so i did haven't had time to take
lessons but hopefully i could it could
prepare me for the
um for that bracket admit you've been
working with maurice right
uh yeah we've i've had two sessions uh
with maurice so far yeah
a little bit you're gonna get ready for
that consolation bracket it should
you know you're gonna avoid these
sardoshes and the benji fishes of the
world so
you feeling good about some of your
chances there yeah
yeah i hope i think i definitely have
some more work to do
overall but uh i definitely i'm excited
i'm excited to go up against my my
consolation brother
constellation bracket is the fun bracket
anyway okay
the winner's bracket they try too hard
they're so sweaty
you don't you don't want to hang out
those people anyway
you know what you're right cutie yeah
bunch of bullies i lost the consolation
bracket when i was in it so i
can't oh no you're fine
listen i mean my fate uh listen i'll be
joining you in the lost consolation
bracket
club so all right maybe they'll invite
you back next time because then
you know underdog story another shot
that's what you shoot for
well we appreciate you both coming on
it's a great match we enjoyed it
and best of luck in the consolation
match and keep up the trash talk i mean
i hope it gets better for you myth and
for nico congrats on the win thank you
thank you and gg smith it was great
it is nico thanks for slaying me out
bye thanks guys oh that was awesome
and well cutie you know your advice to
myth was to get the trash talk going i
try to spur them on a little bit here
but next we have ludwig against codemico
any thoughts cutie any thoughts anything
no i this is i'm sure they will handle
trash talk
um by themselves i don't think i'll need
to do any of that and i don't think
i should make any comments on how i want
the match to go today i i don't think i
should make any
verbal comments about that okay
so this is your version of just pleading
the fifth you're going to stay sun
i'm not going to say anything i just you
know they're both good friends of mine
and i just hope for the best here so
does code miko have
friends because like ai like how does
that work
not to call you out or anything you want
to be code miko's friend because you
never know
what she can do that's she's terrifying
so friendship out of fear that's a great
friendship yeah
yeah i did have a lesson with code miko
and i taught her
the direction of the knights and it was
very exciting for the two of us
i'm glad you had that moment well we
will have a lot of waiting on komiko
next fall by benji fishy
and sardosh but i would like to take a
moment here to thank
guayaqui for supporting product champs
this year as guayaquil celebrates 25
years of regenerative yerba mate
they're sharing cases to celebrate spam
the guayaki emote in chat for your
chance to win and we'll be back after
the break to start the next match of the
[Music]
day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
q anon is not guys you need to get over
the dwight true thing
you actually sound like you not
supporters when you talk about dwight
schrute throwing every five seconds
[Music]
it is just not factual dwight shirt did
not throw
[Music]
i'm on chess.com okay can i ask a
question chess.com
why are we even streaming this is it not
against terms of service
to stream a [ __ ] massacre code miko
is gonna get her [ __ ] pushed in
this is she's gonna quit the game of
chess
okay this it's not gonna be look
i've heard her bots better than her i
made it in eight the other day
what is that move okay
let's get a little it's a little freaky
maybe
surely he takes no okay
surely he takes no okay
[Music]
surely he takes okay
[Music]
uh-huh
let's uh let's do maybe one of
wait surely she takes
why why why would that be the move
even a six what is wrong with you guys
it's you did her so dirty
[Music]
okay
okay all right
i was nervous i was nervous oh my god oh
no i'm gonna lose
weight
[Music]
why why why i don't get it
okay uh let's do let's do a classy
bishop out attacking the queen protected
protected was my last word i worked at
starbucks for five years
yeah you have to say the exact number of
pumps you want
each size comes with a set number of
pumps and it's always
no [ __ ] starbucks so chat they should
tell you they put sugar in their drinks
they should tell you they put sugar in
their drinks people in america believe
in q and on they're not smart enough to
recognize their sugar and drinks
and they're just having too many
calories it should be against the law
how does this game end like this
[Music]
i don't even know how to find a
checkmate here
here
[Music]
[Music]
i don't know how to mate i might not be
able to win this game
if i lose the code mikko's bot i'm going
to feel real bad about myself
check check oh my god
okay all right i don't even know what
i'm doing but that worked out
what does your shirt say i don't want to
show
i don't want to show you guys cutie made
me wear it
i'm not going to show you the shirt
cutie made me wear it i don't want to
wear it
fine
it's stupid it's stupid i hate it i hate
i didn't want to wear it today
she made me wear it it's i but it's
because
i didn't have any clothes clean it's
it's a dumb shirt
i like the color
it's a pretty color
all right chat let's do a bet
not a poll on whether i be code miko a
prediction
over under 20 moves
we'll do 20.5 moves
i don't think code miko
will win but i think she could easily go
over
i think under 20 is really hard to find
a mate
but i think it's a better prediction
it's closer to 50 50 rather than just
doing a 95 pull
[Music]
this is only the beginning
hey me again luscious larry leather
browns
sweaty heavy pocky leathery
wait don't kiss him i'm your son i'm
here from the future
if you kiss him i won't exist so please
hey i love your belt is that what you
wear in the future
rad totally what my grip 6 belt i know
right
i love this no flailing flaps bulging
buckles they're
hideous holes and with a lifetime
guarantee you really can't go
mother
and pog jam 3 presented by grip 6 grip 6
belts are unlike any belt you've ever
had they're comfortable and don't pinch
your gut
with a lifetime warranty it will be the
last belt you ever buy check them out
at go.chest.com grip6 and cutie
we have a great lineup of players
you know them better than i do a lot of
way code miko coming up next but any
players just want to talk about we have
some time
yeah let's let's leak all of their
secrets actually
um pokemane something about her she
actually loves putting peanut butter
between her toes
and um and walking on the beach it's her
favorite thing
that's a serious serious thing ludwig
has worn the same
dirty sweatpants for the past four days
um that he spilled hot sauce on and
he won't change them well the most
important question is what kind of hot
sauce
i don't know but that one's actually
true the other one is not
but i can leak more secrets if you would
like um
yeah i mean i'm happy to hear them but i
guess i'm also happy to talk about how
uh there's a lot of money and awareness
being raised throughout the pog champs
here
you know we are here lots of community
outreach chess.com is willing to match
up to
100 000 of the viewing committee's
donations during the event
and they'll be giving to the
participants preferred non-profit
organizations in the splits you see in
front of you
and the players they've all chosen their
organizations well i shouldn't say all
because i still see two tbas
tbas means to the bank account
that's what that means did you just come
up with that or i stole it from chat
chat is funny sometimes when they try
hard okay gotcha well i i
found it funny i thought it was you so
now you're too honest i would have given
you full credit
oh shoot next time next time it's okay
because i think i think sardosh and xqc
will they'll choose a charity at some
point we think
there's a lot of pressure now now would
be weird if they didn't
yeah although i thought usa when you
live with sardosh that he might be the
champion
and he has a tough matchup today but
he's looked great his reigns almost 1400
i i have a big i think it's going to be
benji i think benji's going to win that
match later today
why is that is it because nico called
him little benji boy child
little benji boy he is the champion in
all of us
he represents all of us if we were good
at video games as a child
and none of us were and that's why we're
unsuccessful and poor
right chad well benji's been putting a
lot of hard work in i've seen
him streaming with grandmaster young
loving hammer uh taking lessons he's
clearly improving
and sardoche as well with nemo i believe
one of the world's best players maxine
russell the grav is giving him lessons
the french community
is coming strong for sardoche
oh i guess it's just it that'll be a fun
game to watch and
totally understand what is going on um
i think this next match with ludwig and
mikko though will just be an
absolute i'm going to feel bad
for mikko i have to say it
i don't have that much faith in ludwig i
just have that little faith in
i i
requires a certain amount of attention
span
that i thought i didn't have but miko
really doesn't have
so the bot doesn't have an attention
span that's worrisome for all of yeah
you know yeah but she will look cute
doing it
and i know that and sometimes that's
half the battle
and well what about ludwig then
i don't know if he's changed his pants
if he has changed his pants
then maybe there's hope but otherwise we
don't know about that look keep doing it
yeah well until that moment i guess uh
your code miko
stan that makes sense and we do also
have great matchups ahead
tomorrow for those of you who will be
back it's the weekend you got nothing
better let's be honest
true pokemon taking on rubius daniel
legrando taking an xqc
those are the group b match ups and then
in group c we have rain wilson versus
logic
and those two have both been very
impressive as they've won their first
two matches
that is the craziest thing how did we
get logic and rain wilson in the same
room
um they were asked and they liked chess
tell me
tell me how much money chess.com had to
switch you tell tell me
tell me i keep doing stuff for free for
chess.com you leak it
you leak it now anybody who's listening
to chess.com streams they know that
danny doesn't pay me so
oh my gosh this is this is insane we you
know what let's
let's revolt let's say nothing let's say
nothing
so you want to sit here in silence yeah
until they pay us
that's right yeah now what
you're still talking i feel like you
made it awkward i was ready to sit in
silence but then you started talking
again and
all right guys fine you don't need to
pay us but you should donate to charity
today that's true because all donations
go to charity right
and chess.com matching up to a hundred
thousand dollars in donations going to
charity
it's certainly a good cause and well
cutie
i don't know how else to preview this
matchup between ludwig and code miko
i think we're all pretty pumped for it
so why don't we take a short break
and then when we return we'll be ready
for the game to begin i'm excited
[Music]
can you see the sun is
[Music]
are we starting soon
[Music]
komiko i'm gonna go e4 f3 with my knight
d4 letting you know right now
and if you go black i'm mirroring
everything you do for 10 moves
[Music]
free move no the only thing i steal from
charlie is
the rest of his content
[Music]
coming soon
[Music]
i changed my pants
i took a shower today
[Music]
my hair is like chill i worked out
[Music]
wait chess.com is watching right now
still
[Music]
hi sweetie how's it going um
i hope you cheer me on in my match i
love you
[Music]
and as per usual cutie i didn't listen
to a word that led how to say how is he
saying
um how's he standing well typically
cocky overconfident and full of [ __ ]
that's usually how he's sounding but i
don't know how he's sounding today i
haven't listened either
so gosh it gotcha expectations are high
clearly
yes yes yes okay um yeah that's fair
and i wonder how code miko's feeling
because after the match against
charlie charlie was saying hey you can
crush lori that bot
nah that's better than he is and there's
a little bit of friendly
rivalry between moist critical and
ludwig
and of course they're meeting in their
final match of the group stage
i'm nervous about that because if
if ludwig wins or i mean if ludwig loses
he's going to be a menace to deal with
and if he wins he's going to be a menace
to deal with
like either way so if you think about
there's nothing to be nervous about
because it's the same result yeah so i
just just i'm just going to need to go
somewhere that day
regardless i just don't want to hang out
with him got it well i heard there's a
good
ice cream place that's in uh disneyland
that you might think about going to
yeah yeah salt and straws and anyone's
ever heard of it
it is so busy all the time and
i recommend them and you want to wait
eight hours
yeah sounds fair and we do have a pretty
breaking announcement which is exciting
that in addition to three matches
we highlighted tomorrow we will also see
pokeman take on xqc
so lots of chess tomorrow four matches
it's going to be a really exciting day
i'm excited i love watching pokey play i
love watching pokey do anything
sounds like you're a fan i'm a big pokey
fan
i've been a big pokey fan got it and you
were
her first chess coach i was her first
chess coach
i got that lesson by telling her that i
could pencil her in
after my lesson after i gave a lesson to
caru
and a gatomater i said maybe i can
squeeze you in let me know if you have
time
yourself and she said wow i would love
if you could make some time for me and i
said of course and i cleared my schedule
just for her
you're just such a generous soul and it
got really awkward when she would ask me
questions
like what should i do now oh they
already started they jumped in yeah but
she could have used your advice before
this situation happened because in the
petrov
after e4 the knight hits the pawn
taking it you should not take back you
need to kick the knight first before you
take this pawn
because of this exact sequence if the
knight moves out of the way
then white will have a discovery so if
the knight goes to f6 this knight moves
it's check on the king and knight c6
picks up the queen
and you can't block that would be a loss
there
uh-oh nico looks slightly confused
and miko's yelling
oh gosh oh my god
feeling a sword
and
i don't say
is mikko okay mikko miko's dealing with
this
on an existential level
and well i was thinking
ludwig almost looks frozen he's thinking
so hard right now
interesting movement if love is frozen
you know something is wrong
because usually a very talkative lad
and look at this logic played pawn to d3
and that's a knight so
miko brings the bishop out to defend the
square but ludwig takes a night for the
cost of just a pawn
i don't think mikko is at the point
where she understands point values we
talked about it
and she kind of hit me with the blah
blah blah blah blah which i understand
um i feel like that's the first thing a
bot should know how to do
is quick accounting that isn't what we
use calculators and everything for
yeah she's a unique unique bot
got it and well ludwig's bopping his
head so i think he feels pretty good
there's a check made in one threat on
the f7 pawn
you think mika will not see this no
no no she
will probably bring out a knight or a
pawn i don't think she will see the
checkmate
and sometimes we forget that it's not
just the palm center tactics if you push
the pawn thinking it's under attack
the queen still goes to that very square
that's an easy thing
to make a mistake about because you
think the queen's capturing the pawn but
no it's trying to go there with
checkmate that's the
bigger thing i mean she's oh yeah oh
and um it's game one
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah uh-huh
yeah yeah yeah it's okay
it happens it's okay the issue is is
right now i guarantee mikko's like how
is that check
and she's looking for it and i'm
listening to love's music
hey hey still better than excuse me bad
winner
bad winner ludwig is bad winner
he does this even when we're in the
living room this is not like
this is not new yeah i mean ludwig is
the far more experienced player
and by the way i just want to give a
shout out to i'm gumby gambit for a
hundred dollar donation that's very
generous
and well a lot of it kind of looks like
gumby out there
and i know that there's a gumby costume
too right he does have a gumby costume
ludwig has a gumby costume
he bought it and then followed it up
with
gumby is attractive or something like
that and i was very confused
because i've never thought that myself
so maybe that donation was from ludwig
but has if you've ever had a crush on a
cartoon character
as a child who was no you just hit me
with a no you don't think lola bunny
was hot like in space jam yeah
i mean no but i guess for some people
wow what about jessica rabbit
also gonna have to pass
simba i mean
you know we're doing all right now yeah
but
yeah you learn a lot about people you
ask them if they like if they're more of
a simba or kovu
a mufasa or a scar you know so what's
your mind mufasa
scar well which one are you attracted to
that's the question
i thought you were calling me one or the
other no got it
um neither can i can i go with that or
do i have to choose one you have to
choose
oh well then scar
perfect yeah right that's wow this is
a lot now we've learned a lot this is
very exciting for you and for your
father who's
watching this um yeah you know he's a
fan of yours
it's not necessarily mine but uh yeah
that i forgot about that
that makes us a little more awkward well
we were hoping to do this um
but besides gumby being attractive mikko
seems to be handling this loss well and
saying that she doesn't even like
chess wow that's a
that's a familiar feeling for all chess
yeah that's how you know that mikko is a
true chess player
i think i think it's a fair reaction
anybody who spends time on a game
and wants to do better when you lose it
sometimes you just say you hate it
and it's fair yeah it hurts because you
care
and well komiko has been in tears in
previous matchups
but we'll see how coco's feeling we're
going to take a break and when we return
we'll be back
for the second part of this match of
production three broad presented by
group six
look guys we're learning chess we're
learning chess everybody
huh
oh
oh i see
um are we playing the next game
take chess.com hey you can turn off
emote only now we only do it more only
when the chess is
when we're playing a game does that make
sense
mods
when we're when we're playing the game
we do emote only when we're not playing
the game
we don't know
freedom hi hey
everybody let technician play
no it is i oh man hey
thank you so much knight source for
gifting 5k1 stuff okay how about this
i will play slower i'll play
slower and
uh i'll try to use
i'll try to think i'll try to think
before i make
moves how's that
yeah i'll try to use my brain
thank you so much for giving five to one
sausage community
i'll make some announcements while we
wait guys so
everybody if you have not already
subscribe to my youtube channel for we
are going to
and we return getting ready for the
second game of the match between ludwig
and code miko
and just want to give a quick chest
pointer out here so in the opening
after e4 e5 knight f3 this pawn is under
attack
so typically black brings the knight out
to c6
because the knight on c6 protects the
pawn e5 instead komiko plays what's
known as the petrol defense it's a
perfectly reasonable move it's played by
some of the best players in the world
but after knight takes e5 you need to
know that taking on e4 is not good
because of exactly what lottery did of
lining up the queen
against the enemy king so d6 is
necessary
that when the knight retreats and the
knight captures on e4
after queen e2 black can interpose the
queen and that way
you save the material so just a little
quick
chest opening run through and thank you
thank you for explaining that i was
gonna do it but i'm happy you did it
ludwig's probably singing a song
yeah well i wanted to take it off your
plate
he does i told you bad winner he is a
bad winner
yeah he destroys her in what was that
eight moves six moves
his eight moves eight moves destroys her
in eight moves and then
goes and celebrates bonk cloud or riot
look
look look look look look very simply
very simply
i'm trying to take this tournament
seriously and uh
you know i also can't believe he's
wearing that shirt for the record i did
not think i'm better than michael
that shirt it's a stupid shirt so i'll
take even the games where i'm so
assured to win as seriously as i can
and put them in the [ __ ] dirt he said
you forced him to wear it
i've been asking him to change his pants
for the last three days i can't make him
do anything
that's not that's crazy
it's that work from home loungewear yeah
he can just
chill in the same sweatpants for oh my
gosh
oh gosh my freaking awesome girlfriend i
can't read
all the fine print but that's she's a
bit crazy she has anger issues but she's
a perfect mixture of sweetheart and
warrior i love her so much
she's my life flirt with me and you'll
be dead or something like that have you
put that to memory or did you just read
that very quickly
okay i made the shirt i wrote it oh okay
got it got it i'm just kidding it's from
amazon i just read it really quickly
wow i couldn't even i could barely see
it i just saw the really large print and
that's about it
all right they're off yeah they'll see
lot of wood knight in c6 to
protect the pawn e5 so now we'll see if
kodmiko goes for bishop c4 the italian
game and yes she does
staring at the pawn on f7 potentially
for attack but i think ludwig
his experience here he knows how to
handle this
miko said she was going to use her brain
this game is what
she learned from the last game she said
i'm going to use my brain this game
the weird thing to hear from a bot brain
bot
really don't go hand together so well
but i think it's working this new tactic
is working
and let's seems hyped he seems
really into this position but he hasn't
moved
what does his mud face say to you
telling a story he's telling a story
you know about the fried liver or
something like it's so fun
and you make money for charity and you
play like it'll take like an hour of
your time
and that's how they pitch it because
they just want big streamers and
youtubers to come on he's just playing
they said to mr beast yo you're gonna
come with this tournament you're
probably gonna get [ __ ]
rolled by people unless you put in like
50 hours a week no
they're like bro hour and a half tops
all right it's so a lot of people come
on and
they get [ __ ] rolled and they don't
realize that everyone might be taking
this tournament seriously
uh because uh they weren't so upfront
about that because
at the end of the day chess.com's motive
is to get more attention to chess and
their website
which is done by getting big people on
but big people don't always have the
time but they're big for a reason it's
because they put time another thing
please play the channel don't be too
hard on contestants who aren't able to
put as much time as
like tofu in the chess it is not
a flaw or a mistake it is just because
they don't really know what they're
signing up for
uh and you know it can make for funny
matches but i just i worry sometimes
about
the competitors who have signed up uh
because
you know this seems like a fun thing to
do and
and then they get [ __ ] destroyed for
not putting in 20 hours a week into a
game that they didn't think they had to
that they didn't think they might have
had to um they thought they'd just do a
few fun coaching lessons
or whatever anyway um
what the hell is even that
see that's what i think i think pogchamp
should be
just fun and it's not our fault that
ludwig is so sweaty and he tries so hard
okay
some of us yes he plays chess every
single night on an alt account he has an
alt chess account not this ludwig ogren
one he literally has an alt check don't
spill his secrets
i'm going to because mikko just wants to
have fun
but why can't you have fun and try hard
at the same time
no absolutely not okay i'm just trying
to
you know stick out for lud skywalker
over here no
no no i just think you know some of us
some of us we just want to have fun we
just want to have a good time myth
myth is one of them you know maybe i'm
just defending being bad
whoa whoa come on don't don't be so hard
on yourself
you approved so much during part two
well yeah well i didn't get invited back
to pog3
so it wasn't my decision
i was super rude of you me
what did i do you didn't ask me no we
didn't have a conversation about this
they told me i didn't have
500 000 subs on youtube so they wouldn't
invite me
back oh well i don't even have a youtube
page so
then they told me they'd invite me to
commentary so i wouldn't call them
sexist again and i said okay
okay well now you're here won't call you
sexist twitch
i mean chess i'll still call twitch
sexist
my bad oh gosh and well
ludwig looking more serious he's biting
his nails
so he's focused he put his knight on g4
going for an attack but i think he knows
better than the take on f2
a lot of people would be tempted into
that because after knight takes f2
it looks like you're hurting the white
king but in this trade
white gets two minor pieces for rook and
a pawn
and the king isn't actually that unsafe
it can quickly drop back and buy donya
taught me that
actually only like three weeks ago and
so i always i always let them do it
and i always it's my favorite trick
it's a good one to keep in mind and well
ludwig does not take on f2 instead of
his knight d4
and he is trying to remove this knight
from f3 so that his queen
can go out to h4 and cause some problems
for him
i see yeah
he is tricky that's definitely what he's
doing you spend a lot of time
with ludwig hess doesn't want you guys
to know but they spend a lot of time
off stream together it's getting a
little weird
i mean i don't know what's weird about
you're making it weird do you want to
talk about your relationship
my relationship with ludwig you mean
that we just casually play chess
sometimes and hang out
every day uh it's not every day
wow in fact was it today no because i
was going to
do some chest him before his match but
here i am
hanging out with you i chose you over
him how does that feel
you're still he's still right here no
but he's not really here
you know you're you're the one letting
him get between
this uh fun time all right
well uh he hasn't
or the knight did wait so he's still
blocked off wait he blocked himself off
with that knight right
yeah because code miko put the pawn to
attack the knight and ludwig just
retreated the knight
and something that was really smart that
happened here is that black is ready to
play pawn c6
because that bishop while it looks
strong with the pawns protecting it it
actually doesn't have any scores to go
to so c6 oh wow
about to happen and ludwig's about to
trap that bishop well he needs to take
care of his king first
and they protected the f7 pawn with the
castle
great that bishop is
locked in there
yes and i think that komiko might have
to take on f7 at some point because that
bishop
is stuck and let me actually miss the
tactic so
this knight is not defended by anything
if the knight on f6 were to hop out the
way
this queen could go ahead and win it so
even a move ago
knight takes bishop after the capture is
happens on the d5 square this knight
can be taken back oh wow you missed
something
oh he's embarrassing um he's wearing the
same
set of sweatpants for the third for the
past three days
that have his gross stain on them
oh so d3 played trying to get the bishop
love it
quickly plays c6 and kodmiko has nothing
better to do
than take on f7 that one
if i if i move this here
this is the most concentrated
i've ever heard okay that's fine you
know what that's fine i'm gonna i'm
gonna go for
[Music]
um
i'm just going to
keep developing like this
and yeah i understand that what happened
he just took my bishop right
so then maybe i'll take hmm
took my bishop that's okay that's okay
it's fine she's not gonna take one of
those pawns
maybe i can go she
should but she's trying to figure out a
way to get active here
i'll just take this there she goes
it's fine well done
it's very pensive she's really thinking
hard here she's really thinking about
her moves here i
this is she's down a minute on ludwig
and he's going fast he's having no mercy
as soon as you see that she just curses
out of nowhere and well we saw what
happened with
charlie yesterday against mr beast when
charles started playing a little too
quickly
mr beast found great ideas to even trap
charles queen so you have to be careful
you don't get overconfident but todd
mikko right now
took on c5 and ludwig now sees that the
queen
can go gobble up that night
yeah this is overwhelming right now oh
she didn't move her
bishop her bishop is free
right does she create a threat but
lovely
true i miss that nobody can just take
well it happens right because you
think about the bishop was hanging a
second ago and now f4 is just like
maybe we'll tunnel on that bishop but
the queen needs to be taken care of
first and larry can just take this pawn
on f4 and continue with the attack
against the white king
so yeah it looks really good for ludwig
he obviously won the first game
he's the much higher rated player uh
very experienced and
i actually didn't see any games from
code miko in the last few days after her
match against charlie
so maybe she wasn't practicing or maybe
she was getting coaching
that i didn't see
yeah i'm not sure if she's doing any off
stream coaching
well you could have lent a hand yeah i
should have as a friend i should have
pitched in a little more this could be
on you but she was
banned for a very long time oh so
well that's not good that's not going to
help yourself yeah
i think she needs your coaching though
well we'll set up a time we'll get in
there
sometimes it's important to have someone
small brain to small brain you know what
i'm saying because
donya will talk to me let me talk to me
and i'll be like stop i don't understand
the thing you're saying
it seems like you do understand things
they're saying because you took
levy's advice played the stonewall you
had some lessons i love the stonewall
so you took the advice you learned so i
yeah but i didn't understand the
stonewall until i literally broke it
down
in a weird way that i understood it
like the f file represents frozen and we
play with anna and elsa it's it's very
confusing
but that's how i understand it i didn't
know that's how
yeah i mean elaborate sounds my teachers
have a really hard job
is all we could say
i think that's where's olaf in the
equation olaf doesn't play he's not
invited he melted
oh that got sad real yeah well i mean
yeah there's something does come out
well there are kids oh i know i know
there are kids that watch chess.com i
get the complaint emails
okay just stay off tuesdays and
thursdays from 8 pm to 10 i'm on
chess.com
don't watch if you're easily offended
i'm sorry
i can't change for you it's fair
and well ludwig does not take this
bishop on c5 you mentioned that
a while ago that that bishop could have
been captured and even at this moment
the bishop was still under attack so a
lot of it going for
his development putting his queen why is
he not taking that i don't understand
because he just knows it's free
we need some material for the post-match
interview so
i don't know the answer let's save that
off for him
he's laughing though and he's also
rewinding in his game
he's he's playing with his foot have we
been in
so four turns each we've just let this
hang here
that's [ __ ] absurd
[Music]
nine
[Music]
it's crazy because i know that mikko
this is why
chess and i hate to break it to a lot of
people watching this is why chess does
not equal iq
i know that miko is smarter than ludwig
1000 million percent but then when
people are like
oh he's she's bad at chess so she's
stupid
oh gosh get off your high school she
moves to e1 she's a genius
yeah those takes are terrible snap
intakes are terrible
so it's mate let's thank you no it's got
the thinking music on
[Music]
all right fun little uh pin here
oh
[Music]
he's got this
cutie is a checkmate on the next move if
the king goes there if he brings his
knight in
wow this is such a sick checkmate oh wow
yeah i see that
what a dope mate yep okay
no no i don't know his every move but
sometimes i can
get a read and he's he's pumped
he's pumped he's pumped and do nothing
mikko is fine okay
mikko will survive yes
and has not been doing that much chess
blood reggie is grinding as you although
he has not had time
to change his sweatpants because he's
working so hard in his chest
yeah that's true he did shower today
though so that's very exciting for us
he's making progress i mean you got to
be proud of him
yeah it's baby steps sometimes you just
have to lower expectations
so that way we can appreciate the little
things i'm excited to see
how miko um takes on the
consolation bracket yeah i think that
with some training and a little more
experience that me
codemigo can do really well uh she just
had such a tough
two matches against charlie who's been
practicing very hard and against
two of the higher rated players in the
field i'm just here i think
i actually think and this is being
honest and it might upset some people i
think that
the consolation bracket is more fun to
watch because you can't
you can't you never can guess what's
going to happen
compared to you know higher level it's
it's very you
people know theories and they know lines
and they know all that stuff that i
don't even know if i'm using the right
words you are
theory is right yeah opening lines
variations yeah that's crazy
but i i just like i like watching bad
chess i think it's more fun i don't want
to get better
at chess because then it's it's less fun
to me it's just harder and it requires
more thinking and that
that's not fun am i crazy
do you love hard chess chess is fun
you know i like it but now that you put
it in those terms
now you feel bad about your hobby yeah
what am i supposed to say now
i feel like it's not kind of singled out
you can say it stays fun because it's
just like a
more of a challenge it does stay fun
because it's kind of like endless in a
way
where you learn something new every game
and if that weren't the case then magnus
carlsen he car
they would be perfect players which
nobody is
and so they're the best players in the
world out there and yet they still can
make mistakes so there's always
something to learn from but if you get
too good don't you go insane that's like
a thing they say about chess players
all right it's time to go to break and
when returned we will have ludwig and
code miko in for interviews
okay i played 57 bullet games on the
15th
and that is like a long day for me i
don't play on my i hardly ever play on
my second account or third account
um yeah but he plays 46 games of rapid
you know
rapid rocks was playing lcs today yes
it's gonna be very exciting
oh that reminds me um i gotta go at six
because
cog is actually gonna play so
dude sir dosh is just
bill diff honestly like sir josh has
built that he's played 46 games
like yesterday on my longest day of
chess streaming
this whole week i've played 57 games of
bullet
this guy's played 46 games of rapid
hello chess.com hello everybody watching
pogchamps
i am so hyped dude
honestly sir dosh is just crazy like
he's played way too much chess
like how much has he played this entire
week i'm just like stalking one of my
students
he's played 272 games this week let's
see how many i've played and keep in
mind i'm
like a full-time chess content creator i
played 104
he's played almost triple the amount of
games i've played in a singular week
no i'm not friendzoning somebody again
okay we're past that we're past that
yeah and i play bullet like he's played
a 272 games on rapid like if you just do
the time calculation
how many hours is he spending on chess
like per day
how many is that like how how many hours
i mean how many hours has he streamed
10 hours easy
like does he have a life i mean okay
never mind forget i asked that question
he does not have a life i already know
the answer to that it's fine
but like wow it's actually just crazy
like because
sometimes he plays really well and then
sometimes he's just like straight ends
you know like this last game we looked
at he just straight into it but then the
game before that he was doing really
well
so i think honestly you just think he's
like take a chill pill
i hope he's actually taking that bath
and not
don't forget guys i'm actually following
him on live chest to make sure he's not
playing
any chest while he's taking his bath so
that he can actually relax a little bit
yeah i mean look it's okay to not have a
life but it's another thing to
be so try hard that
you play he's playing so much he's
playing so much
he's actually playing a real chess head
too no
like i'm literally like babysitting his
mental as well
so um i'm literally like
babysitting his mental to make sure that
he does not
die during the matches and also it's
really funny because i saw another tweet
the other day
about how he wanted a chef because he
keeps living a dj life
and i'm like maybe he played one less
rapid game a day
he could actually cook his own food
maybe maybe
like just maybe if he play one less
rapid game
he could cook you know
like i don't know is that is that a wild
gossip is that is that a crazy concept
like if he just plays one less game he
he has time to do a lot
like okay me cooking is that a crazy
concept it's never gonna happen
me cooking is not gonna happen i
actually was supposed to go out and buy
groceries today
and then so josh wanted okay so i was
like okay okay
but it's fine it's fine like
i will i will eat at some point i will
eat at some point
he's literally hiring a chef i know i
need a higher chef too
but it's okay i mean he's streaming
around 3k hours a year i guess that's
kind of crazy
it's actually pretty insane but like
like okay when i played him look at okay
like i'm obviously instructing him
through all of these openings but he
actually picked up this opening pretty
fast
at least i hope he did i think he's
gonna come back and be like oh [ __ ] i
forgot everything
so now i'm stressed because maybe i
stress him out too much
thanks my girl for the tier one thank
you welcome to the pool party
i i i think like maybe i would have
stressed him out too much
but it's fine
i will not do a cooking stream i haven't
eaten breakfast yet it's currently 5 p.m
i need to go eat some breakfast
but he has a second account
i'm gonna stream his match no i have to
watch clg play i think cogs
and we return with the players a lot of
we congrats on the 2-0 score there
and first question is when's the last
time you change your sweatpants
okay can cutie cinderella
never be accepted to do commentary again
if she's gonna harass me
and talk [ __ ] on me i changed my sweats
i changed them oh okay finally
oh finally mine arse i worked
out this morning and i was wearing a
dirty shirt
for a workout what am i supposed to wear
a button down now for workouts
no it was like three days old dirty
covered in hot sauce
oh yeah no it's a working man's shirt
i'm a working man i wear a working man's
shirt
you play video games on a computer
not even i react to stuff it's different
video cases okay and i broke a sweat so
look at this
so i'm it's hard to work stressed him
out
i was stressed out on the italian game
really
yeah you played a pretty tight italian
at the start and i don't know what i was
doing
no way are you being sarcastic no being
dead ass and then you made like eight
blunders then i was fine but until then
i was pretty nervous
yeah we do have to say again the
argument of
being good at chess does not necessarily
equal high iq ludwig had a hard time
finding the link
to this meeting even though he's had it
so just more
um discord channel it's different
research no from the playing chess i've
found that most
chess players actual dog water in the
head they just put all their stock and
iq points
into uh figuring out moves and uh
you know what since i'm also dog water
in the head i'm trying to get good at
this game as well
it would be nice to be good at something
except for you hes
you in the opening here if we go through
the moves i think that what loving was
saying is
you did a very good opening plan with
your bishop about the c4 because you're
starting to put pressure on black's king
and you then move the same piece twice
so by moving the bishop a second time
you delayed
your other development whereas if you
had castled first and
brought some of your other pieces out it
could be more difficult for ludwig to
meet but when you brought the piece out
another time and then you did a good job
of protecting the bishop
the problem was that your bishop had no
more squares to go to so ludwig
was able to recognize that and then
moved his knight away
after this where when he came for your
king
and he plays now your bishop is out of
squares because your pawn
your two pawns are taking it away oh
you [ __ ] blocked yourself yeah i can see
that now
yeah that was that's not how i would
have phrased it
but you know i've discovered uh a lot of
the things
in the way i phrase things are not how
the chess world would
uh it's uh you know remind us of what's
wrong with the chess world again i want
to hear all of it
did i did i bait the producers into
going to me when i was when i seemed
distraught
that was my five head play of the day uh
look there's nothing wrong with the
chess world it's just that
sometimes chat can be a little harsh
against the people who uh who sign up
for this tournament and at the end of
the day they're just
just.com is trying to get viewers right
hey
it doesn't matter if mr beast goes 0-18
you got mr b's viewers here that's
that's all we need go the game or
something right
isn't the quote start start start it up
rev it up
why are you singling mr beast out he
played really well in his two matches
well because i like mr beast and i feel
like if i single anyone else out i'll
feel mean
i don't mind with mr b's i think jimmy
can handle it oh code mika what's the
experience women
like for you learning the game and you
know just getting started
and you had two tough opponents thus far
how are you feeling as you get more
matches on your belt
um i'm having fun i just started playing
just not too long ago
so i want to keep playing and get better
and better
but i've been having a lot of fun moist
and ludwig is really nice so it's really
nice to play again you don't have to lie
yeah wait did you say ludwig is nice
yeah that looks nice i didn't know he
has such hygienic problems he always
seems so
fresh and clean on the stream all the
time
i'm minty i smell great no you look like
you smell great but
i guess looks can be very deceiving
thank you cutie for that i feel like
this is mostly you're doing miko is a
dear friend of mine
so it's nice to hear yeah well
amigo are you going to do any lessons
maybe with cutie cinderella any more
lessons
mikko i would love to do more lessons
with you can you
teach me how to beat ludwig well i can't
even beat ludwig
oh
[Music]
which in this case i don't know just
frankly i mean chess
chess.com does have the four player
modes so maybe
me miko and hess against you ludwig well
maybe 2v2 me and has first youtube
boys versus girls i am
i for sure am i just think really i love
this boys versus girls idea i would love
to latch on that house would you rather
be on our team or his team
everything's great cool for me
yeah well speaking of buggers you have
one more match-up
left against charlie yeah any friendly
words for charlie
i found out i don't know how someone
knew this that i in lifetime
six in nine against charlie uh i have
won nine games he has won six
nice so my goal is to draw it
okay so you're planning to draw your
games
yeah i want to draw both games otherwise
we lose it
yeah sounds like a great thing to hear
from somebody that you've uh
been trying to help win games well you
know as uh
in chess the fun fact drawing can
oftentimes be as good as winning
some people at lower levels might not go
for draws when they should
true and who does mikko play next mr
beast oh that'll be a juicer miko you're
going to lose i think
mr beast is going to prep opening moves
so whatever you do just don't play what
you've been playing make up something
brand new
really yeah he look he's a savant he had
every move i played and mapped out so
eight moves out oh
yeah he's a little he's a little cuckoo
we'll just play the italian everyone
plays the italian right
i'm going to teach you something called
the stonewall mika what's that
no that's what you should say gotta get
over the stone
we love the stonewall you've been
playing it for a year just do anything
else say
just try something it's always stonewall
this michelin taught me this
occasionally
you want to talk about you want to talk
about that anyway anything else you want
to add
well why am i getting throwback to me i
don't want to get involved in this
situation here
in fact cutie cinderella we are
co-commentators we're completely equal
here
anything you'd like to say to ludwig he
um
as an adult man uh he still wets the bed
and i want you guys to know that
wait what all right see you guys later
uh-oh i don't know how to leave the call
i don't want to leave the place
why do you still wet the bed get me out
of the [ __ ] call producers
dirty twenty-five i figured it out i
figured out i'm leaving i'm leaving i
don't want it that way
you have to wear them
well we love having the players involved
here
cutie cinderella i think you did a great
job of sufficiently
exposing ludwig you know thank you thank
you it might not have been true but at
least it
made him laugh not him the chat yes
you are now a fan favorite for sure and
ludwig he wins to
nothing he's been a favorite of many of
the commentators they've been impressed
by his play
today kodmiko was outmatched and
honestly the next one we have in front
of us
that's the matchup that many people have
been waiting for because that's the
heavyweight battle of benji fishy
and sardoche so before we go to our
a break and come back for that third
round
any thoughts on that matchup cutie i am
really excited for that i think this is
going to be some high
level gameplay from both of these two
and um
i am totally gonna understand what's
going on the entire time
um because i too play above a thousand
and it should be great to watch some
people that are also as
good as me and play things like the um
aficionados and stuff
it's about time and well we're going to
take a quick break before we do we just
want to give another shout out to
guayaqui for helping make pogchamps
possible as gwaiki's celebrates 25 years
of regenerative yerba mate
they're sharing cases to celebrate spam
the guayaqui emote in chat
for your chance to win four pillars of
regeneration to heal
all nations we work with and not against
because we are a part of this we've
never been apart from this
saw hands feel through the soils past
our
feet touch on the blades of grass raid
all these voices into a beautiful
tapestry find those similarities we all
share in these breaths that we breathe
this home of ours sustains us but needs
us
so together we'll move through this long
night and inspire us all to come to life
well i eat i'm deciding right now do i
want do i want sushi
macdonald
okay wait what i want i i got italia i
kind of wanted italian today let's see
what uber eats actually has
i'm really hungry i need a chef for 36.
kebab
you guys like kebabs
i can't get that so that's pretty sad i
kind of want indian food again though
i know i love floating that's pretty fun
oh i'm on chess tv uh
i'm literally just debating what i want
to eat honestly
i'm very hungry but i'm way too
emotionally invested in this upcoming
match
so play one less rapid game
cook but you don't understand i'm like i
need
i actually need
[Music]
uh
he needs to relax a little bit i mean
this one's easy he just has to play rook
there
are my quarter french we should probably
put the process
from french i i'm not french at all
i can just speak french because i lived
in france and i grew up in canada
i have to adapt yeah he did it
he's 80 he's almost 900 in puzzles this
is crazy
okay okay
he's gonna get 1900 before his game i
mean i guess that's gonna make up for
him dropping like 50 rating today
so pizzas want a chestnut gold twitch
pull all right guys i'm ordering pizza
did they actually vote okay i will
actually get pizza
because the viewers the viewers wanted
it if you guys want if you guys want a
pizza i'll get pizza
i mean honestly i'm up for whatever so
okay let's order some really good pizza
what's something really awesome
okay so pizza um
i mean i live in toronto do you guys
know pico do you guys
should i get like italian pizza anything
except
like anything except pizza pizza pizza
is pretty good
we're getting pizza oh
i love this question because it's gonna
this is gonna be the biggest debate
all right i'm muting sir josh for a
moment
do you like pineapple on pizza
pineapple pizza yes or no type one in
the chat if yes
one's in the chat if you like pineapple
i'm not gonna lie
i actually like pineapple on pizza and i
have not had hawaiian pizza
in a hot minute 1.5
dude i actually really really really
enjoy
hawaiian pizza
we are no it's pretty good it's pretty
good no
desert i see you saying cut transmission
on the chest.com chat
okay i see you guys i see you guys um
okay i think
do you guys know little caesar i don't
actually like little caesars i think i'm
gonna go for something that's a little
bit more
uh not chained and more of a like home
baked i really want pizza on a fire that
sounds really good no you can't
unsubscribe waiver you just subscribe
today
oh i could get caesar salad to go oh
yeah actually you know what oh i'm so
hungry right now i'm so hungry okay
i'm gonna get pizza with caesar salad
this is really nice um
restaurant okay i'm trying to not dox my
address here but like
this looks good this looks so good i
love this
this is gonna look really good okay this
is like a classical italian kind of
restaurant
i guess we have around here um
there's a lot of good stuff i don't even
know what i want
i didn't leak anything
chill uh but pizza in canada is not very
cheap unfortunately
um as you guys know there's this thing
called pizza pizza and pizza pizza is
pretty
terrible but it's cheap pizza if you
want good quality pizza it's pretty
expensive
so yeah oh chat wanted pepperoni pizza
okay we'll get pepperoni pizza um
all right so pepperoni pizza
just don't forget order yeah i'll
actually order how expensive
it's like 15 bucks for like a
medium-sized pizza if it's not from like
a shitty place you know like a terrible
place
pepperoni wins on chess.com
it's actually pretty expensive pizza
there's a lot of different pizza choices
there's north of brooklyn pizaria this
sounds
medium pepperoni pizza is 20 bucks by
the way
20 bucks by the way
that's a bit of a scam i'm not gonna lie
i might just go back to pizza pizza
like that's kind of expensive
i'm not lying i'm not joking that's like
a little bit expensive
but like i feel like there has to be
something a little
like something that's not pizza pizza
bad pizza but like
not that i deserve a good pizza
i mean it's 15 canadian bucks so like
it's not like
let me play you 1v1 chess for 100
best out of three games blitz rating 900
smile the last time somebody did this
it was a little bit sus that's all i'm
gonna say
that's all i'm gonna say
but like i'm down to do it just not
today
[Music]
so
[Music]
hawk champs 3 is presented by grip 6 and
grip 6 has sold out of the chest team
wallets but check out their wide
selection of while it's available they
still have the amazing chess belts 3
options available
the queen king and knight all with 3
different strap options
find them at go.chest.com grip6
judy i think they need a cutie
cinderella belt honestly uh well you
forgot to mention they can use code
pogchamps 20 for 20
off uh hello i'm trying to save the
discounts for myself
i know those things run out quick shoot
okay fine
okay fine i won't tell anybody um yeah
i don't think we need a cutie belt i
don't want to be closer to any of
buddy's um anyway uh so what are we
looking at now
oh wow well community outreach the
complete opposite of what we were just
talking about so
chess.com will match up to 100 000
of the viewing community's donations
during the event donations will be given
to participants preferred
non-profit organizations in the split
you see on screen in front of you
and just a reminder of what
organizations those are the players have
made their choices
el sardos and xqc still need to make
theirs but we see unicef
we see the one drop foundation and
across the board you know mr beast st
jude's a lot of great causes yeah i i
personally i love the humane society i
always um
donate my money to the humane society
which is bad because i see that's
critical's
charity and now i automatically want him
to win but that'll make ludwig sad so
i'm in a weird spot there but
i love i love the humane society i love
the work that they do so
we'll see what happens yeah hard to root
for anybody based on these causes so
many
great ones and well we will have
the final games of the group stage and
after the group stage we have
the bracket so the championship bracket
it will look
like this the group a winner takes on
the second place from group b
on the other side of the bracket the
group b winner takes on second place
from group a
c and d do the same themselves and so we
will see some
great matches we don't know what they
will be because
the results are not in but if we look at
the current standings
we have potential match ups for example
of daniel negranu taking on
the loser of today's match between
sardosh and benji fishy
and the winner of benji fishy sutterish
will take on whoever finishes second
place
in group b so those kind of matchups wow
clear
yeah okay i'm interested to see
yeah how this game just turns out i'm
not sure like i've said i've said it a
hundred times today i feel benji and
sardosh they're just both
they're both so good that i'm just gonna
pretend like i have hot takes and
chat this is what i need you to do i
just need you to say yep and go along
with it okay
no matter what i say i yep
i'm with you i got your back i agree
with you
thank you thank you so much and you just
timed all the yeps
because here they come and what people
are about to be pumped about
is tomorrow's matchups because we have
four
in store we start with pokeman taking on
rubius
okay my queen my queen pokeyman please
go back re-announce that
you'll be seeing her twice look at her
she's there
two times on the screen because group b
will have
another match up daniel negrano taking
xqc then you have rain wilson and logic
fighting for first place in group c and
then finally xqc and pokemon that
matchup that was postponed
it will be happening tomorrow 4 20 p.m
and it's between xqc and who again
remind me
queen the queen pokemane everyone please
bow how do you they prove that they
bowed
uh they spam yep got it so you're just
continuing to farm the yeps
yep got it and well
speaking of farming you can take down
not say these players but their bots
farm some rating off of them pokemon bot
ludwig code miko
xqc nico and mr beast all of these
bots of the players who are taking part
in i
played all of these bots last night
actually every single one
how'd you do good i beat every single
one
whoa yeah i had the biggest problem with
mr beast
actually is it what was it about mystery
i had to play
i had to yeah he was too he gave me too
much money i was like wow
uh i had to play him three times before
i beat him i don't know why
maybe he just felt bad honestly my chat
was telling me that it was because
his opening countered the stonewall and
all i use is the stonewall
and if mr beast is known for anything
it's not his
youtube prowess not his great
philanthropic causes it's for knowing
how to out prepare his opponent's chest
from it yeah yeah
yeah i hate when that happens yeah well
you took down all the bots this is why
there can't be a bot of you because then
people will win and we can't see cutie
lose right
that's what they keep telling me but i
think it's a lie well
there's a bot of me i didn't ask them
for it in fact i didn't want it to
happen but it
was against my permission i really
didn't want that to happen
i asked weekly yeah and that's why is he
the opposite what happened i didn't want
one
and one was made you want one and some
it's just maybe just
just don't want it can i have hesses
just give me hesis he doesn't even want
his
same skill level come on you haven't
seen that's messed up i think can we
make it happen chess.com can cutie
cinderella just take over my butt
i feel like that works well forever give
it a hair a little longer
yeah they said no smiley face
disappointing we do have a lot to smile
about because we have had generous
donations
from andre we also had
the paddywagon a hundred dollars chess
for charity thank you so much for your
generous support reminder to everybody
that chess.com is matching up to a
hundred thousand dollars
in donations all going to charity of the
players choosings so this is a great
cause and we really appreciate it
i love twitch usernames i don't know if
i mean yours is easy gm has very
professional i had an
interview with a danish newspaper about
chess
actually why danish how did that happen
i don't know
okay it just happened okay um because
i'm known for my great
chess plays plays and um
and they had to say what's your name and
i said blaire and then he said what's
your username on twitch and i had to be
like
beauty cinderella so i only imagine how
paddywagon69
feels wait
why just say with pride what's wrong
with cutie cinderella it's a great name
because i have to spell it out i have to
be like oh the letter q yeah
the letter t and then cinderella like
the princess
yes i'm 26. like you know like
yeah like it's just a little
embarrassing i don't want to say so
we're going to take a quick break and
when we return we will be ready with the
benji fishy
sardosh matchup stay tuned
we're going to take a quick break and
we'll turn we will be ready with the
benji face no
not a break stay tuned no not more
what okay let's let's watch someone else
on twitch then
um oh dudes they're featuring me okay
then i'm gonna do some puzzles let's go
again let's go again let's go again
let's let's watch someone else on twitch
then um
let's go back to puzzles okay here we go
chuck mate
chuck mate chuck mate chuck mate
chuck mate chuck mate chuck mate
check checkmate check make the queen
uh checkmate
you can obviously take b3 that's
probably just check check and mate
check and take the rook take the bishop
um take the juicer
check mate there's obviously just
takes and checkmate checkmate
white pawns go up the board so you take
you push bring the king take and then
you make a queen
that's good checkmate
now you just take take and just take
uh check and mate there you go
[Music]
believe it's check
another 20 subs thank you for the 140
subs that you've gifted
today thank you so much my man you are
amazing thank you
um let's go shock let's take the juicer
let's take the queen
let's go shock and then we go d7 and
make the queen
now we just take fossilize the bishop
take the juicer
we just take we go check take the juicer
uh i assume you can go here go thank you
for the great content and countless
hours of entertainment
so king g3 i actually i'm a little bit
confused as to what this puzzle is
exactly
for other games or shows i don't know
what it is it's
because king e3 is all no okay it's got
to be here
don't be stupid okay you go check and
potential ice skater in the back
now you go here eat eat fork and eat the
queen
um there's queen d8 here and now you
just go
check take the queen this is good i
think you can just go checking a7
that should be right just push under cr8
take the juicer
now you can just take oh it's c5
moving trying to move too fast and theme
with the uh
with the show okay let's still get to 50
before before they come back let's go
oh wait the rook is pinned wait the rook
is pinned okay let's let's start again
let's start again the rook is pinned
um let's go
this is the uh the arabian checkmate you
know you always want to learn some of
these checkmates
check that's winning let's go takes you
to cutie jelly for the five gifted thank
you so much to qt jolly
qt jelly for the five gifted thank you
so much
at first i was about to say cutie i was
about to say cutie jelly cinderella
let's go here let's go get here um
let's take a checkmate um
uh is it quincy one i think i think it's
queen b2 if i'm not mistaken
no i'm just wondering okay let's let's
let's just go again
let's do one more yeah i was about to
say cutie jelly cinderella yeah okay
last one we'll get we'll get to 50. how
much time do i have before they return
to the official broadcast you guys uh
takes and takes let's go check and let's
take
um 40 seconds to get get to 50 okay
check
drop back um it's good
take just takes that's good take the
juicer on d3
checkmate um check check take the queen
54 underscore check check cakes that's
good just
takes that's good just check take the
queen that's good i assume it's king g4
and then take the queen that's good you
go chuck chuck take the queen that's
good
um takes takes it's good
uh takes takes takes
takes takes takes
takes check takes takes
um i think it just takes there
check d4 take a juicer i think it's rook
f1 if i'm not crazy
um am i crazy though wait there's also
queenie two wait a second i gotta be
careful
wait a second it's actually not trivial
no no it is i'm stupid check check
takes takes and then you move the king
to the corner you take
and then you slow dive underscore just
subscribe
take take move the king how many times i
say takes takes there way too many
okay obviously he takes takes
and we return ready for our final match
of the day that is between
benji fishy and sardoche two of the top
competitors
they've been working their tails off
beauty now's the time you got to make a
choice
is it benji is it sardosh okay listen
if you've ever watched my stream you
know
and this is so irrelevant and chat some
of you probably don't know
i'm have always been a massive bjergsen
simp
um i'm a league of legends girl that's
where i started was league of legends
and sartosh is also a mid laner in
league of legends
and anybody who's ever been maybe a
competition for bjergsen uh-uh i'm not
your fan so i'm going all benjy here
wow well benji needs all the support he
can get because sardocia's rating is
14.50
what what have they been feeding this
guy oh i don't know i'm nervous but
i i really hope for benji oh apparently
he's a jungler this is so awkward
oh um never mind you'd like to take back
everything i said
a lot of awkward moments here
i feel like it gets less awkward if you
just make it public right i just
put candy in my mouth and it was like a
weird
distraction yes and uh well
moves not being played that quickly so
both players taking their time i wonder
what their coaches said to them about
the other player because
they have been improving and grand
master eulogic hammer has been coaching
benji fishy
and this move c4 so a lot of people in
polychams don't actually challenge the
center with c4
they often play bishop f4 for the london
system instead we see
c4 and c6 by sardos this is
to me showing that they've really
studied because he's creating a pawn
chain
rather than taking the pawn c4 directly
yeah that's what i was going to say
that's so great i would like um
um yeah i'm joking
i'm joking i don't know they're both
good i don't know what to say yes
i thought you were physically choking
for a second you just told me you were
talking of candy and i was worried for
your hair
nervous this is the first time i've
choked the entire episode
you're screaming and saying you're
choking and that is a hazard
all right i was worried some people like
that um
anyway uh back to the game
oh gosh well black has the pawn chain
towards the center
white devotes the bishop to d3 so often
when the bishop develops
now is the time that black takes because
you don't get to recapture in one move
but the players are leaving the tensions
the sign that they've been improving
that they've been studying because i
think when you're less experienced you
take as quickly as possible
when given the opportunity
i agree
join me join me when you look at this
position
what are you thinking about there's not
a single piece has been traded i
think it's very different than how i
play i get very excited and any low elo
players that are watching if you're like
me
i would just i would want to take take
take take take that's what keeps me
entertained
um i am sad that no one has used the
stonewall opening this entire day
i think that that's disappointing magnus
carlson used it recently and that was
exciting for me um but it just doesn't
get enough attention
and that's what i know about chess is
the stonewall so i will always talk
about the stonewall
so do you think that magnus watched your
stream
absolutely all right just making sure
that you're on the same page
i think he might have yeah being
inspired by other creators that's
the sign of a brilliant chess player yes
but here would it be um
oh never mind never mind i was gonna say
would it be
what would you do next here well the
thing is not a single piece has been
traded so that's
i would say the uh struggle right now is
what to do because nothing's been traded
and
benji plays b3 to protect his pawn
support with another pawn
and well sodor says i'm going to play h6
and they're actually playing a really
high level game this to this point
taking on f6 would unnecessarily give up
the bishop pair
whereas this knight's not really going
anywhere it can move
but then you're willing to trade the
bishops and this knight has nowhere good
to move so
by not trading qt they're leaving this
tension and creating
difficulties for their opponent so it's
just not restricting their opponent's
chances to play something active i mean
i've said
i've said we love fortnite you know i'm
a big for what are you doing
ah you haven't said where you want to go
where do i want to go yeah who do you
think's going to win
um well i don't know that's why i asked
you i just thought that you would figure
it out
and i don't know you want to place bets
i don't
is that legal chess.com ten dollars
hess i have ten dollars on benchy but
then i now have to have a rooting
interest i stay neutral on these things
are we supposed to say neutral you have
ten dollars on benji that's brave
and no odds because charge is the higher
rate of player
[ __ ] so i mean i i kind of want to take
those odds never mind
it's like if you even bet a high rate
player that feels good for me you take
it back
i mean feel like we didn't shake okay
well b5 was played so sardoce is taking
up more space you sure that
it's too late yeah mm-hmm
looking forward as ten dollars okay
anyway so b5 played challenging this
pawn structure another time
but benji doesn't even need to move it
because his pawn is defending and his
bishop is defending again
and it's 10 moves in cutie zero trades
i'm sure you're maulding over there
i'm losing my mind yeah i was told
by levy always take whenever you can
you said that yeah always take even if
you lose pieces
he's my favorite coach oh okay
that's good strategy sometimes i can get
behind it
and levy is now pulling out all of his
hair in chat
he's never said that to me but if i said
it then it's true
i didn't think he said it until he makes
a video about it
you're not believable i had i had one
night uh
i don't know if you guys know a a rook
king mate
is very difficult and it's really hard
for me and i had one night
it was like two in the morning and i was
just spamming levy until he got on a
call with me to walk me through it
so he's a good he is a good he's a good
coach i'll take back my joke
and he taught you your favorite opening
so and he taught me the stonewall
sounds good my favorite opening so
that's something a great coach
inspiring causing you to you know fall
in love with
aspects of the game i think there's
nothing more that needs to be said
and well benji has done something i
think is really good but you're not
going to be happy about it
because instead of trading he pushed his
pawn forward to c5
creating interesting connection and
black's pieces
are kind of like stepping on each
other's toes this pawn on c5
is a big thorn it takes away the b6
square from that knight
the bishop on e7 can't really move
because this configuration here says
you're limited in scope so that's wow oh
you're a fan of that move it sounds like
perhaps yeah perhaps a trade here right
because the bishop
that's his option he could take or he
could just ignore it
so he does okay there we go we have a
trade
they are recognizing that pieces can
come off the board don't need to keep
them all
proud of this development one of the big
things here cutie is
this pawn structure for white is really
strong
and when you have a pawn chain the pawn
chain is only as strong as the base of
its chain so the f2 pawn is very safe
so what black wants to do in the near
future is play e5
to start chiseling at the pawn chain to
create the bass
closer to black pieces and make it
easier to attack it
yeah that's what i always do too i know
you do you're a stonewall player so
you know about pawn chains
yeah i wonder um
i wonder what's going through their
heads right now i
i'm they're on call with each other
right
i hope they're talking some smack
while on call while playing why not
so she's just quietly listening to music
come on
is just like the soothing music but yeah
kind of motivating at the same time
what's your go-to chess playlist
oh i typically don't listen to music
when i'm playing but if i am
i'm just getting like a random kind of
hype music
sometimes let's get kind of popular
music leon bridges always
can listen to him no matter what i'm
doing okay
all right okay i can't tell if that was
an okay of approval or okay
like what's wrong with you who's leon
bridges whoa
whoa that bridges is so awesome
yeah you're gonna have to go on spotify
later i can send you some
songs i got you in discord i'm a taylor
swift and taylor swift only family
okay i would like her bought on
chess.com please
but like she would say some really sad
things that she lost
she's like i'm gonna write a song about
this
and it'll just be a sad one and this
position
is looking kind of sad for black right
now because benji
bringing his pieces in and this knight
can go to e5 so
it's not like black is in danger of
losing the game anytime soon
it's just hard to play this way when you
don't have any active plans and white is
the one trying to press for it
yeah come on benji take that knight to
e5 and then you
get a pawn right hypothetically you get
that pawn on c6
right and how do you like that bishop on
c8 cutie
that bishop on c8 is just
stuck he is stuck
the tall pawn that's what we call that
yeah like every step cyst you've ever
had he is just wedged in there
yeah it can't get out and that's the
problem with black's position and
white's pieces are better
pretty much every piece except for this
knight on e4 for black is worse
and a4 that you saw the engine it kind
of dropped a bit
and i didn't like the move b4 i think
that at that moment
soto should have taken on a4 and then
open the position up maybe try to trade
bishops
and finally get his pieces out but the
engine says white's still
much better even in that scenario all
right best ten dollars i've
ever won wait you took the bet
back no wait what we agreed on it
okay sure i see how this goes yeah
actually maybe what starters did is even
better because he planted
his knight potentially on the c3 square
and white has this good known e5 but in
comes that knight to c3 that could
be problematic good thing we never shook
on it so
wait you keep going back and forth i'm
so confused
so do we have ten dollars on this or not
we'll see
okay i get it if you win i owe you ten
dollars
nothing happens correct yes that is true
it takes a while for chess players to
process these things i understand
and well cutie benji does have that
bishop that you like in the stonewall
and it is aiming
well trying to aim towards black's king
so at some point we may see the move
pawn f3 to kick that knight
and open up the diagonal that is my
favorite mate
he's checking the h7 yeah mm-hmm it's
the only one i know
is that ladder mate is that your
favorite uh bishop
that's a rook is bishop on b7
no he's so stuck i don't know what he's
doing oh he just protected that pawn
from the night i understand now
well that's sad when your piece is
defending just a mere pawn and that's
why pawns do so well
when they're connected with one another
you don't have to use a greater resource
to fit
to defend the least valuable people g
chat oh and
aaron at the queen oh i was staring at
the chat staring at the queen yes
do not blend your queen i don't think
benji will he looks really well
in fact we just have his forehead both
foreheads you just see one eyeball of
benji's peering
at the board it's kind of creepy i've
seen enough horror movies to know how
this might end
oh queen d2 played all right saving the
queen
and there's just no tension in the
position the atmosphere is tense i mean
they're just
trying to figure out what to do but
there's no pieces
attacking one another and no pawns that
can be traded and i like the move by
stardust there to trade off white's most
aggressive piece this 95 or this knight
on f6 that wasn't exactly doing anything
yeah the clocks are pretty even too yes
just no now just under five minutes for
benji and 540
for sardosh and well i like to move 97
trying to make some trades
what do you think is this knight on c3
it bothers me do you think that white
at some point soon should try to bring
the knight back from f4 and kick it out
of there
i think i think that's a great idea uh
i guess i guess that's that is that's
what i would do
and well i guess and benji
wants you to win those ten dollars come
on benji
come on you know it's a good move
trading off black's
most aggressive piece there we go yep
there goes the trade
and this bishop on b7 is so bad
and a big problem is maybe you'd want to
trade that bishop on a6
but you can't do that with this queen
and bishop on the same diagonal covering
the a6 square so first
you see the capture here and now what
white can do clean up the board
you start pushing pawns on the king side
like to advance
your pieces here as black doesn't have
good control so
they still have that h7 check available
that's right if we can line the queen
and the bishop up there that could be a
checkmate
so we have many ideas with trying to
line up the queen bishop
expanding with f4 and maybe keep pushing
the pawns and black
feels a little stuck
and chat is all in french now yeah
yeah i do uh i do speak a bit of french
do you understand it's going too fast
for me no
i don't it's way too fast i think
they're singing a song
very good chat you guys are you guys are
talented
seriously impressive copy pasting
yeah yeah the best
and so sorry i was thinking now it's
even on the clock again this
is probably the best match i've seen
thus far
in apollo jumps all due respect the
other players but this feels
really intense and neither player giving
up ground rook a7
that is a move that you would not expect
and look at benji go
pushing upon ford and i'm guessing rook
a7 was played
to go rook a8 there it is and bishop es6
he recognized the need
to trade off his terrible bishop for
benji's good one
wow
that's that's some five head stuff
and do you know how many hours they've
both put into this game recently
i have no idea but i see that sardosh
every time i
look at twitch he's playing or with a
new coach i think he was with nemo just
a couple hours ago
so he's working very hard right that's
amazing
i do not and this it's intense it's
interesting to see how each person
handles the competition yeah
i mean it's really hard work paying off
for both of them
f5 you saw the engine drop and the
reason why is this pawn on e5
lost its defender so chest often is
about timing and now that black took
this pawn e5 is going to be one that can
quickly get under attack so rook takes
f5 here will defend the pawn temporarily
but then this bishop
can slide back to c8 attack the rook and
become useful for a change
that'll be exciting for him could would
it no
i was i always do this and i mess up
where i do something strange where i
like
sacrifice a rook in order to get that h7
right and that could happen actually
because if you somehow get this rook
captured and your queen can land on f5
there could be a checkmate
with the queen of the bishop but right
now if benji plants
his rook on f6 swings his other rook to
f1 there could be a devastating attack
against black's king
that would be exciting i hope he sees
that he's thinking about where to move
the rook
and rook f6 is the most aggressive
square
it also lines up a potential sacrifice
you were talking about sacrificing
pieces to go for a checkmate
the rook on f6 could do just that
so benji demon thought but he's getting
down to that
just over three minute territory sardosh
a bit ahead in the clock
and i think bendy trying to recognize
you know what's changed my rook's under
attack i see that
but also what's changed the pawn on g7
was covering f6 oh
okay instead of retreats
and i get that sometimes you worry about
putting your pieces too far up the board
but rook on f6 would have kept
this pawn in place and created more
threats if the rook's here this pawn's
under attack
this pawn's under attack it's
challenging black
more than the rope back in f3 but he is
creating that battery right that battery
with the two of them
give me one free move i will gladly take
this pawn in f7
so how would you go about and defending
that pawn to here uh is there
maybe a piece that hasn't been doing
much i mean he just has to move that
oh i was thinking he'd move that bishop
and then expose the rook but i guess
this is what he's doing
you're right though bishop back was
better the rook on a7 would have
protected but look at this
this pawn was under attack but now it's
pinned and if benji sees it
bishop takes g6 steals a pawn
did you see benji he kind of threw
himself back in his chair i think he
sees it
fingers crossed okay
he's got his hand up he feels ready to
play his move
he's down under three minutes sardosha
had the clock but that was a big swing
if benji takes that pawn he does he
takes it nice
okay
and look at this that
king is now open sardoche did not see
that coming now that it's on the board
you were talking about that queen
getting in cuny it's looking more and
more likely
so that looks like a problem but what
can white do here right
it's either i think this is the wrong
move but i i would probably do it
would be to take that pawn
with the bishop on yeah and then he's in
check
but it doesn't really buy i guess it's
just a waste of a move well it would be
a great move
if the rook on a7 were first to capture
so you're looking tactically
as a way to distract but unfortunately
after bishop takes up some the
f 8 rook can take back and save the day
so i think benji is best off just
retreating his bishop
hard to do when you just stole a pawn
you're all up
yeah you're so excited to be up there
just bring it back and this king is
still exposed
this is nice this commentary today is
nice because it's just a free chess
lesson for me
you know i thought i was the one
learning from you so i could let me
teach you the stonewall
anytime i need to learn it i haven't
ever studied it so i would appreciate
your guidance
it's great i agree it looks great when
when you win games with it so i don't
often but i'm
just trying to you know who's the morale
okay
i am getting nervous for benji's time a
little bit
i am as well and i think he's trying to
figure out because
this bishop is hitting the queen and the
rook on the same diagonal
that's a problem for him he needs to see
that his bishop can just retreat back
which saves the material and still
leaves black's king
out in the open
uh we're spending too much time and i i
don't think he sees it
based on the time consumption no i don't
think he sees it either
that's the hardest thing and this is
gonna be very stupid and you guys gonna
be like yeah forehead cutie
uh to remember is that your your bishops
can move back ah
any sacrifice the rook
i actually don't think it's stupid at
all i think that's a mistake that is
very commonly made one of the hardest
things to find in chess is retreating
night moves and treating moves in
general are
easily missed all the time and now the
problem for
benji is he lost a rook for a bishop he
still has attacking chances
but the rook for bishop dynamic should
be good
for sudden if he can handle this well
there but there's still pressure and i
don't think that
sodos is out of the woods yet i'm
nervous about the time someone text
sardosh something tell him his
refrigerator's running or something
maybe don't text the players because
that could
constitute some problematic behavior
with a little cheating you get some
texts and moves but
well benji wins i get
ten dollars how did you come up with a
refrigerator that's like a thing
you've never gotten that prank call no
not a single time oh is your
refrigerator running hess
yeah all the time oh you better go catch
it
now you know oh that that hurt to hear
yeah
i'm actually upset i know i'm so so is
everyone
everyone's upset look at vengeance
there's actually a big attack queen 65
is not a free pawn
don't go take that because rook g3 check
you see that evar skyrocket
yeah kingdom's up you keep giving checks
and the king has to go in the corner
massive come on benji we have a minute
so i think that sardoch knows better
than to leave the defense of his king
by taking a pawn don't get greedy here
he's already out material
hey benji i need you to focus right now
focus on the clock
come up with your move right now that's
what i do and then i always do the wrong
move
it's a really good tactic i recommend it
maybe you'll have to coach these players
in advance the next one
yeah they would be upset that i wasted
their time
i don't think anyone feels that way it's
always a good time which is
never a waste of time so okay so i was
thinking
he could get himself the time trouble
and his king's the one that's more open
so
kitty playing these positions open king
i feel like that's
often scarier than having a material
deficit
yeah i agree uh
i i think he's pretty safe to start
playing oh
oh he did it no my gosh he did it he
called it he's in checkmated by
force come on does he see it i thought
it was my analysis board for a second
and then i looked and
no the engine's got he does see it there
he sees it
oh gosh oh no queen f6 it's all forest
it's all forces mate it's it's checkmate
on the spot
that's it's done and look at sardoce
oh my gosh
i can't believe it
[Music]
i think 12. he plays fortnight
and let's see when the checkmate happens
if we get a reaction look how happy he
is
there he is oh my gosh all right
ten dollars everybody ten dollars what
do you mean ten dollars that's only the
first game
oh yeah it's we did on each match oh
okay so yeah everyone in chat owes you
ten dollars
yep i think that's fair so go over to
the cutie cinderella's channel
and make me holla yeah throw those ten
dollars her wish you called it and
that's a
huge upset because sardoche was seen as
maybe the favor of the entire event up
with the likes of rain wilson getting a
lot of love logic playing well of course
blood is
is too but sardosa's rating is so high
and people said this could be
a preview for the ultimate championship
and
benji said i'm here to play i may be
young but i can do this thing and he
delivers a checkmate
i've actually been saying it i i've said
it on my stream that i think the end
i think benji will go pretty far to of
course i have ludwig all the way
i think he is going to win the whole
thing um
but i think benji's going to get really
really far
playing games like this he out of the
gates was doing extremely well
he let it slip a bit but he had the
attack on his mind the board opened up
and sardos you could tell he just didn't
see all the tactics and he was really
upset with himself because he's like i
should have known better i had a feeling
things were off and just a couple moves
before the end here the queen on e7 a
very important defender
making sure that the enemy queen doesn't
get in so
he spent a lot of time on that move yeah
he did
and i wonder if he forgot that the queen
could go to f6
and this is something that happens all
the time because you may see the check
on this diagonal right that's the entire
length of the board
but after queen c5 rook g3 check king
agent if you check in the corner
maybe starters was looking at queen c3
to block the check
and say no checkmate for you i'm in fact
i'm just taking advantage
but benji says nope up i go
and there goes the checkmate oh great so
great
we're impressed look at this chest today
huh the weather's great and the chest
is even better see this is what happens
though cutie at first the position was
really close no trades were happening
we were thinking oh come on go get some
pieces off but
chess at their level right now it said
it doesn't end
with necessarily a queen blonde or
anything like that we need to be patient
we need to wait for opportunities
sardosh won in exchange benji quickly
struck back
it is one nothing in benji fishy's favor
we'll be back shortly for more for
pogchamps 3 presented by grip6
whole first match because yes i i like i
said when i saw benji play the second
game
it was very very good um so i was very
very impressed okay let's uh let's do
more puzzles then in the meantime so i
think we're still being featured on
chess.com right
yes we're being featured so let's do
puzzles let me pause this
okay this is white to play and win here
there's knight h6 knight g5 there's also
just
h6 h7 take the queen this is good oh
from your stonewall cutie
that this bishop on d3 is the most
important part of your attack
yeah so you're trying to trade off that
bishop before it even gets out
and soter says nope no trade for you and
then look at benji strike
right back in this world wow what is
happening here lots of pawn tension
in both sides they're just hanging out
they're getting ice cream together
and hopefully they can do that in a
short span of time it doesn't have to
require a huge line and they're both
playing really fast right now
i think this is a mistake on sardosha's
part because
he needs to win this game and he has
plenty of time right now so instead of
playing bishop to d3
you look at this position with the pawn
tension you want to figure out can i go
and take one of these pawns should i
throw in a check
you always want to look for checks maybe
queen a4 check is a good move
bishop d3 is by no means a bad move and
benji quickly castles
but it felt like he didn't know what to
do so he felt the urge to play quickly
if you remember game one though he was
the one ahead on the clock
yeah and
i'll look at bench he knows the plans
this is not someone memorizing an
opening this is somebody understanding
because he brought his bishop back to e7
he didn't like the pin here
and now you have the bishop on d3 you
have the bishop on h4
but lining up an attack is difficult
because one of the best ways to stop an
attack
is by creating threats elsewhere on the
board and with this tension
all over the place here in the center
white doesn't have a free hand on the
king's side i like i like benji
constantly does that like
that like there's like a word for it
that like serial killer stare
at the chessboard just like looking up
at it and it's terrifying i think
i think that gives him a bit of an upper
hand in case sardoche
looks at him it's really scary kubrick
kubrick stare that's what it's called
doesn't look like sardosh has been
looking up at the cameras very often
he's just been staring down yeah he's
concentrating he's kind of shaking right
now
well benji's playing that well it's
causing him some fear and
well knight e5 played jumping up with
the knight
benji can trade knights that will hurt
white's pawn structure instead he goes
queen
c7 to defend the knight but there's a oh
there's a big tactic here
knight takes c6 queen takes e6 and when
the pawn takes on d5
i hit your queen and i hit your bishop
on a6 so
oh wow yeah there's tactics like this
maybe white should take the knight first
but either way you will take on d5
and this bishop is hanging so let's see
what the players have done no
bishop g3 oh interesting
yeah he doesn't he doesn't go for the
trades he keeps the tension and it's a
good move
it just so happened that there was a
better move based on the
location of the pieces
so much tension here you know what time
it is
no i thought there could be a stonewall
situation with that pond going out
that is not a stone wall do you even
know the stonewall that's not the
stonewall how dare you
i ask you to teach me but you're too
busy teaching pokey and code mikko and
everybody else
that's not the stone wall i'm sorry
i'm sorry gm's these days they don't
even know all the freaking openings
that's crazy
i'm sorry embarrassing for you honestly
well now you have to take the reins here
because
i feel awkward well he's not doing the
stonewall is what i can say he's it's
long gone there's no stonewall left here
if he would have done the stonewall that
f pawn would have been on
f4 but he did just take that pawn that's
exciting development
i was trying to get the pawn to f4 that
was part of my plan oh
well then this is awkward well that's
just the delayed stonewall not quite the
same
and nice it's raid benji quickly trading
i think he's gonna keep going he can put
a rook on d8
in line with the queen at the end of the
road
and there could be some tactics here
that favor black so i think benji can
put a rook on d8 he can also
take on d4 start trading some more and
black has no
weaknesses in the position nothing to
gang up on and so he should
have the better position between these
two players
hmm so who who is up right now
i i can't keep track of the pieces it's
even in terms of material
oh okay great
and i'm trying to make the claim that
black is doing very well
because you can take on d4
and that would leave white with an
isolated pawn so after pawn 64 for
example i see
pawn takes pawns best friends another
pawn you don't have the defense of
another pawn
so i can pile up and start attacking you
that'd be really exciting
you don't sound that excited i i i just
i looked over at at levy in the chat he
said women gm
keck w oh that that's a personal attack
and it
that did feel like a personal attack and
i don't know why because we're here
watching the same game
levy all right who took your job
[ __ ] it was me i was about to say who's
on the big screen in the answer who's on
the big screen
big guy huh who's here
yeah so i thought this sounds like a
fractured
relationship in terms of we do chess
coaching demolition
i'm the only woman that will go on his
stream i
i feel like the thing you could do to
hurt him the most is stop playing the
stonewall
like no matter what you say it's not
going to be defective he'd be so happy
if i stopped playing the stone
he'd be like finally she's doing a new
opening it's been a year
it's been one year finally but that's
loyalty at its finest
oh yeah i don't know it's the only thing
that stuck to my brain
it's very obnoxious that the only voice
that sticks in my brain is levies
oh yeah but there's a lot of content so
if you just keep watching the
videos that go up on youtube and there's
more
intake and hey that's a a learned voice
i want levy to do more videos with lucy
though
where are the lucy videos where's the
lucy content levy
oh um yeah maybe he'll analyze these
games with lucy
because these games have been good and
more content the merrier
oh okay now we're talking
and well look at oh no
oh no that's so i get the point by benji
trying to take advantage of the pin
but white has two knights and the pawn
all staring at the e5 square
wow very good idea unfortunately the
execution doesn't quite work in this
moment
so he's going to take it with his knight
of course right
and that night is the uh
that night uh c night and you can offer
us some trades and pieces and
you love that you take on d4 i can take
back and for now white is a pawn ahead
and that's not good news for benji
although his position as you can see
based on the engine
it's still quite decent because white's
gonna have a hard time keeping that
extra pawn
and sodosh takes it we actually are
seeing the sequence
i have to take back on e2 with the queen
and now benji's in for a tough
think because you can either take on e4
or take on e5
and he should spend time calculating the
difference between the two
mm-hmm yeah and for the record
for any chess chess chat members that
don't understand what a sense of humor
is
levy and i are best friends so yeah we
make fun of each other a little bit but
at the end of the day we're best friends
all right levy oh that that changed real
quick
yeah well you have to be honest
sometimes unfortunately people don't
understand anymore
oh oh oh oh oh oh
when pieces are in line with the queen
you go and try to pin them
oh that was a rush decision still a good
position for
sardosh but go back a half step here
rook to c1 or queen to c4 you
pile up and you pin the piece and win
the piece so this would have been
a great opportunity for starters to
level the match instead he takes on c6
and his idea is that when the queen
takes on c6 he will take on d4
white will still be a pawn ahead so it's
a good decision
it makes sense but he had a move that
would have netted more material he did
move that really quickly
yes do you think that a clock is just a
vital part of the strategy
maybe i mean they seem so close on time
um that maybe he knew that he was just
trying to get a bit of an upper
hand makes sense because
you know he had a lead on the clock in
the first game and he had a good
position i'm sure he was analyzing it
during the break between the games so he
should be feeling confident about his
chest there was nothing in that first
game that
led me to believe that he should feel
anything but good about the way he's
been playing
and now he is upon ahead though
it's not clear cutie how to use that
pawn because it's the pawn e3
and it does protect the knight but as
the game continues you need to create
past pawns and try to win
um uh i think my
my next move here would just to bring
that that rook to
c1 to attack that queen okay
that's why benji moved off but rook to
see one is still
yeah take over the open file
and it's not easy for
uh for white to figure out a way to
press forward because you want to push
your pawns but if you start pushing your
pawn to f3
that could potentially create weaknesses
around your king so any pawn push you
make
that's a permanent decision because
pawns can't move backwards
and his his pawn structure in front of
his king is just a complete
complete barricade they seem to both
be kind of tiptoeing around
an idea here like both kind of avoiding
yeah they're playing a little copycat
but they make sense because they're
fighting for an open file
and black and double the default or
black can bring the rook to c8 and try
to use the c file so both sides are
doing the right thing as there are two
open files next to each other they're
trying to figure out which one is best
to operate on i do with wish shardosh
would use his other
rook that rook being tucked in that
corner is making me very sad
so you think that his next move is just
going to be bringing the rook over
i hope so i think that's gonna be his
move
i think i'll play it pretty quickly
there it is there it is
okey dokey and
benji down one pawn but now down two
minutes
and there's no clear plan for black you
just kind of have to sit tight
and ask sardis what are you going to do
to beat me in this position
because you only have one pawn and
neither of us are attacking the other
so you know cutie these positions i
think are some of the most difficult in
chess
yeah the it's interesting
this time deficit is the biggest it's
ever been
over two minutes and well do you think
that benji
you know he can handle it he is
obviously an uh
amazing esporter can we call him that
how would he call it yeah he's an e he's
a
yeah he's an east esport esport player
e athlete just an
athlete okay we can just call it an
athlete oh okay you just told me that
ludwig wore these same sweatpants for
four days in a row
that doesn't sound like an athlete well
his excuse was why change if you're
gonna get him dirty again
so maybe he's just smart he's honest
maybe he's onto something yeah potential
it looks like sardosh is now in the
think tank here trying to come up with
an actual plan
rather than just making you know good
moves and it's important to do so
but you need plans behind your moves and
this knight e4
well placed by benji if he plays pawn f3
down goes this g3 pawn you don't want to
drop a pawn in this position
but he needs to figure out how to push
forward
from this point
and it's really not clear i think these
are some of the hardest positions qd and
chess to play
because there's no checkmate attack to
go with there's no
weakness that's clearly yeah it's very
scary
right i'm happy to see sardo really
really thinking this out
yeah he brings his queen back to e1 so i
think he's trying to protect
this pawn on g3 so that maybe he can
play f3 next and
kick this knight out and he doesn't drop
the pawn here
i don't know it's uh an interesting idea
and i think that's what i would do i'm
always gonna just agree
with whatever you say yeah what did what
did he just do oh he just dropped his
queen down
interesting you don't have to agree with
me come on well
i don't know stonewall i should not be
agreeing it's too late to do the
stonewall
it's absolutely too late i didn't mean
to bring up
i don't understand why you think how the
stonewall is played at the end game but
it's not it's an opening
it's an opening hess i will learn one
day i was just going to say that
i don't know everything chess players
make mistakes we're human you know
things happen
and i didn't mean to bring up the
stonewall again so no more stonewall for
me
but this rook is under attack so so
that's scary
yes don't want that it's very very scary
i wonder
goodness there's no
there's no checks here i just don't i
i don't know what i would do i think i
would just move the rook
and keep tiptoeing around i don't know
what to do here and
that's probably what you should do and
you say you don't know what to do and
well you need to move away for starters
but let's say you bring the rook back
and the knight comes back to attack your
rook
you're gonna have to do something
otherwise we'll just be repeating you're
just gonna be repeating
yeah but then that equals a draw correct
that would be a draw which
black you know benji's up one uh point
here
he wants to draw and sardoch of course
wants to play for a win
yeah i would take a draw yeah so i think
sardosh is going to switch the files
of his rook so instead of keeping the
rook on the d file he'll go rook c2
and rook c1 and the reason why is this
pawn defends this knight
so you don't need your rooks on this
file they can happily shift
to the c file and try to go for
a breakthrough on that line
oh this is just so stressful
and while the players are feeling it
benji down under four minutes
and you see that sardosh four minutes 40
seconds
a bit of a lead on the clock white is
upon ahead he just needs to come up with
a plan and another
idea that i'm just coming up with here
and he plays f3 which keeps
yeah keeping that knight out maybe he
can push the pawn himself
but i was also looking at a b4 b5 push
so you can get the c6 square for your
knight you can anchor that knight in
on a more advanced square
not out of the question so
not easy to play this seriously cutie
it's just every single move
you need to figure out what's my
opponent thinking are they actually
threatening anything it seems like no
but you can be lulled into a false sense
of security and then that's when the
biggest mistakes happen
i think i think benji's next move here
is it too soon to get your king involved
i don't know when
when in the end game is it too soon to
get your king involved it's a good
question
i think with the queens on the board
it's a bit too soon
okay because if the king goes towards
the center black or white whoever's king
is going to center there are enough
pieces
remaining to start attacking that king
and so i think benji is just trying to
poke and prod brings the queen to a6 the
queen on b7 was just shut down by this
pawn f3
so now there's an attack on the pawn
here the queen you know has some nice
open scope
not that it amounts to much it's an
empty diagonal but at least it can
pretend to do something
you seem deep and conscious uh i'm
looking at i'm looking at this
his night and i'm curious and again chad
i'm just
i'm giving a much lower perspective here
okay i'm 900 rated i'm just going to say
that knight moving there because then
it's looking at that bishop
and now the queen's not there to protect
the bishop
right the rooks here rook rook i get
bishop and rook confused i don't know
why
i got you covered i knew exactly what
you meant and there are actually some
devious threats here that black needs to
be very careful about
because i could see this ending in a
checkmate pretty soon for white here it
goes after queen takes
queen takes a2 if you take this in comes
the queen of d8 with check
and after king h7 there's knight e7
trying to bring the queen here
and checkmate this king and there's big
danger for black
this could be very scary okay
let's see wait check okay 97 oh my gosh
oh oh no watch out here so the
move that black should play is push your
f-pawn because benji's queen is actually
eyeing the g8 square through the pawn so
push that pawn up the board oh wow and
you can save the day
you can save the day here and look at
benji deep in thought
what a cool mate i love any mates with
with a knight i think they're very cool
this you really don't see this very
often but it's because black's pieces
are all out
over there on the queen side not helping
the king and
you're asking you know when can you
bring the king out not in this position
even a queen at night that's enough
material to land a checkmating attack
so this is very scary for benji he's
thinking he needs to push the pawn
i think that there's no other way to
save the king besides pushing the pawn
up the board
i hope he sees it i don't i don't i
i think he will just because he's
surprised me a few times and you know
he's desperately looking right now
you know that he knows that there's got
to be a way
and he could be thinking about pushing
the pawn up to make space for the king
the problem is the queen will stop on g8
then go to h8 and this king is going on
a walk up the board
and actually checkmated in the next move
after queen takes pawn so let's show
that very quickly
if h5 queen g8 up keep check it's force
checkmate there's nothing that black can
do and that would be a checkmate
wow let's see
no move yet no move played by ben oh
he's got a minute come on veggie
oh and he's not streaming so we can't
see oh oh no
it's gonna be this exact checkmate it's
going to be the checkmate
here comes sodor sees it no question
he's going
to do this mate oh boy
oh boy oh oh he blew the queen
oh my oh my gosh you blunted the queen
does benji see it does benji see it
benji do you see this oh he has to see
it look at benji's face he's in shock
oh he took the queen and sardosh loses
the queen
benji is so confused he's smiling
no the tragedy not the queen
oh oh my god benji is smiling
sardosha's melting he's melting
oh no played a great game
and that's so frustrating in chess you
play a fantastic game
he was playing so well and on
one turn doesn't see the queen on the
opposite the board
full board awareness needs to see these
things and unfortunately for sodos
he is laughing at himself he is laughing
at himself
at least he's not crying well it's a
botez gambit for the ages
and benji fishy wins the group
a great match by benji but did get the
benefit of that blunder there
both of these players look like serious
contenders and benji fishy
wins the group two nothing in this match
what more is there to say cutie i just
i'm just
i i'm so proud of benji you know
he just feels like my new best friend
and i've been rooting for him this whole
time and so he is going to teach me play
fortnite and then i'll make millions of
dollars
quick question so levy was your best
friend just like a couple minutes ago
and now benji's your best friend dude
i'll say it [ __ ] levy i hate that guy
oh okay well before he can mulled in the
chat let's go to our final break we'll
be back with the players in just a few
took another second to not blunder his
queen
[Music]
but absolutely nuts play
[Music]
oh [ __ ] uh wait uh
french surrendering again
oh looks like only one frenchman took
down the w today
oh it was me was it nuts
only room for one of these tournaments
son
and it's not you
by the way interestingly i looked at the
bracket
and what this now means is that uh the
winner of group
a is benji fishy so he's going to be
here
sardoche will be here uh and then who
wins between me and charlie
will dictate whether we're on sardoshi's
or benji's side
i don't know if i really want either to
be honest but
here's the dangerous part whoever
loses with me and charlie on sunday
will almost assuredly be playing rayne
wilson
which is [ __ ] terrifying because we
play the winner of group
c for second place so if
i lose to charlie tomorrow i would have
to beat rayne wilson
and then presumably uh i would have to
play
benji fishy if he keeps going on the
path he's going on
so this side of the bracket is [ __ ]
this is rayne wilson and benjy fishy
this side of the bracket i think is a
bit easier i think it's a bit
easier it would be uh depending on who
wins between me and charlie and then
like daniel negranu uh maybe if xqc
loses
you know i'm not too worried sardosh
you know i'm not worried about that so
we'll see
we'll see it's gonna be a tight bracket
i regret winning i wish i could just go
to the consolation bracket you make more
money for getting first in the
consolation than last in the [ __ ]
championship
it's horse [ __ ] everyone's too cracked
at this [ __ ] game
i put it so many hours give me a
easy bracket for once chess.com
stop giving me this 16 year old cracked
ass kids
i can't handle it just let me have a
freebie one time in my life
i'm losing it
[Music]
if i lose to 16 year old i'm gonna i'm
gonna cry i will cry live on stream
i'll never stream again and not to be
ageist
but i'm 25. and i've been like
practicing for like a year
do i at least have more subscribers on
youtube than benji fishy
what did i do with these nine extra
[ __ ] years what have i done
what was the point of having nine extra
years i don't
this is [ __ ] is he tall
don't tell me he's also tall is he tall
bendy fishy height
[Music]
let's go let's go
suck it benji suck it
god picked me
oh that's justice
but seriously if i lose to someone who
wasn't even alive for 9 11
that's [ __ ] up
he's 16 yeah good i hope he doesn't grow
until 17.
i don't care what he does after i'm not
in a tournament with him
all right this is the small temporal of
time that i care about
i just need to be taller than him in
this like hopefully he doesn't have a
summer growth spurt
that's all i care
and we're back with both players benji
fishy
wins two nothing over sardosh both of
you played amazingly well i have to say
that
i think this was the closest match and
the best played match of the entire
event
so benji i want to start with you can
you just tell everybody what you've been
doing how much you've been practicing
and it is clearly paying off uh yeah
i've been practicing as much as i can uh
you know i've got like
fortnight tournaments but you know
whenever i have spare time
um i i just really enjoy playing it's a
this is a
nice hobby of mine i i just really enjoy
and i want to
i'm a competitive guy so i want to get
you know as good as possible at it
for sure and so what about you um
every time i open twitch you're playing
chess or studying with a new coach
seems like you're taking this very
seriously and you did play great chess
of course
both games ended on what's you know look
like blunders in your end but you were
really playing well throughout
well i i don't know i
first of all it was one of my intense
game
uh i played for my whole life so
i wasn't used to be focused for so long
in a chess game
for at first and then
well i i'm a bit sad because i lost bot
game boss game because of
tactics i was supposed to be
slightly worse than benji
concerning positional stuff and close
position because he used to close the
position and uh
i used to open up i play an open silent
play
well i couldn't play my stuff and he
trained he prepared very well against my
london system so
i i was a bit confused at first but i
always managed to get
out of the first position better and
i get too confident i guess so i'm super
i'm super ashamed actually to
that i have done this mistake because i
already expected to win this tactic and
no you played amazing and i know
obviously the result stings but i have
to reiterate that time and time again
you
really played excellent even in this
moment i brought up the boarder you're
talking about positional
uh benji you kind of locked the position
this bishop on b7 was stuck here but i
like the way you both played this first
you
sardosh bringing the knight to d7
excellent move and then benji
instead of taking this knight you
brought your knight back keeping as
close as possible so
kind of what was your thought process
like at this position benji i'll start
with you
um i wanted to to get rid of this night
basically and i i don't know i didn't
really like my night being there
uh or like my well i didn't like his
night being there
so i was like oh i might as well just
try and get it out and then
try attacking his king sides uh since
i'd the
the queen side like locked basically all
closed
uh yeah that was basically not too much
for processing it but yeah such a casual
way to articulate your thought on such
an intense game plan like holy cow
yeah and i mean and so those on your end
of things and after this trade sequence
everything started to improve at this
moment where benji
you had the right idea but it was a
little bit too soon
because after the capture which soros
did perfectly
and the move bishop seat really hard
move to play
generally speaking dropping your bishop
back but sotos did you consider this
move
um uh honestly
uh i i didn't really consider it because
i felt like it would just run away and
uh i will lose tempo i don't know uh
first of all i i told you you would take
with the bishop and i was able to take
this pawn on e5
and then open up the position but he did
the right thing taking with his uh
well with the brochure oh yeah yeah and
you had the right idea g6 is a good move
it just so happens that
bishop c would have kept your pawn
structure a little safer because in the
next few moves
we saw what happened with rook f5 that
was a nice tactical shot by you
uh benji whereas point the rook on f8
walked into this pin
but still you follow really well with
bishop a6 just to immediately okay i may
have lost the pawn
but let me go on the attack myself so
benjamin
uh quick question for you did you see
the bishop retreat that you could play
this or
will you thinking that bishop was an
attacking piece and kind of overlooked
that it could come back to your defense
yeah i i didn't see that i'm gonna be
honest i didn't see that i can't
i didn't see it actually
i kind of just i was opening it after
this i was like oh i'm about to lose one
out of bricks i'm like
i need to try and i know just look for a
checkmate
i mean okay so i guess it worked but i
got pretty lucky
to be honest um i'm just i'm happy i i
did it i saw it at least i'm happy i saw
the checkmate yeah it was really nice
and
it's i was saying to cudi during the
commentary that
it's really difficult these are the
hardest things to think about is
backwards you know these retreating
moves
especially when your bishop just took a
pawn and came in the attack
but this would have saved material and
sadosha and i know this is going to be
painful
but at this point here you end up taking
on c5 what was your thought process what
were you calculating and what was it
that you overlooked i don't know i
i completely miscalculated the queen
could actually follow up and
well it's so stupid because i just have
to push my pawn on the e
on dnc and i could just win the game i
guess
i could just close up the position stall
he was close in time so i could just
push my opponent and play the final
will be quite an easy final i think
um i'm not sure maybe i was well i i
think i had a lead
but i don't know both games i missed
tactics maybe because i woke up too
early i'm tired and
it just plays so well it pushed me to my
last uh
my last uh wants of energy i was like
i was like too it just played where i
i had to blunder at some points and he
played so so perfect during all that
time
and i honestly prod i lost in game like
this well
my blunder are something but overall i
think games were really
really great and we showed up some grits
we just show up that europe is better
than an a in the structure
okay yeah i mean in in the second game
starters you were one move away from
checkmating yeah man
i just took the opponent and said okay
he can't actually uh
remove i will mat in one no matter what
so i will play it the safe way i i
actually imagined the the combo with
knight and i felt like okay this is too
complicated
uh i will focus on super thing just take
the and treat the mat in one and
i didn't see the queen in my head queen
was attacking so it couldn't
she couldn't be able to defend for some
reason i
i break up the board in two pieces and
i completely know that they could come
back and so then
i think that's the theme of both games
honestly with retreating moves are very
hard to see so it's something just
uh to check for on both iran's and serge
i mean you should keep your head
held high you were one move away from
evening the match and it felt like a
very back and forth struggle
so i think you both should be proud of
the way you played but i think i did a
mistake in the white game at the end
because i needed to
kick off the night before going for my
place with uh because if i don't do that
i believe
he will just take my opponent and ignore
my i think when he took the rook it was
a mistake actually
um because he could just told because he
has bishop
and rook covering the pieces so he had
three pawn basically
and i i was summoned at myself when i
missed uh
it was maybe b5 or or before to kick off
the
the night and yeah well i didn't pay
perfect but
we will meet up again i think this year
yeah i think so too
you did really well you need to give
yourself more credit you keep talking
about how well benji played but you
played out of your mind
yeah you really did and you won't have a
chance to meet again i don't think
unless you meet in the finals you'll be
on the opposite sides of the bracket so
you can avoid each other for the time
being and i mean benji
huge congrats and so the highest rated
player in the field at this point
it felt like a really intense struggle
of both parts what are you
planning to do as you both head into the
championship bracket
uh i'm just gonna i'm just gonna keep
playing you know i mean it's not i'm
just gonna keep doing what i've been
doing
uh it works pretty good you know i'm
getting coached uh every day by hammer
which is helping a lot um i think i'm
improving uh really fast and
yeah hopefully we can meet again in the
final also benji i heard that you're
actually
six three which is four inches taller
than ludwig is that true
that that is correct yeah right very
cool
correcting the uh the height out there
that people are
googling and putting out but um i know
it's gonna
sting for a bit but what's your plan how
do you recover from this i mean you
obviously had painful losses in your
life before but so how do you
bounce back honestly first of all uh i
wasn't confident with my opening
uh my black opening it was maybe the
first time i played it in a game
because i didn't find spring partner to
play that i just
knew the theory oh i needed to play
against the english
opening so i need to train it a bit more
if i want to match uh benji
because i wasn't playing perfect in my
opinion and soon
while i i would just play and try to
grind uh
i just want to say one thing because
most of the people in
the english cast told that i was
actually coached by maxim vashilagar but
it's not true he's actually full
triading with the chain backrow for the
candidate tournament so he has actually
no time to talk with me or help me and i
would love to but
sadly he's not up for that so if you
heard that maxim is helping me it's not
true i'm basically playing
a lot of game alone and nemsco and kevin
uh body are
helping me a lot for this so i will try
to make them proud in the next game and
with my best in quarter finals and i
open it again
well i think they definitely are proud
and honestly it was me starting the
false rumors i heard that
maxine was somehow in the bunch my my
apologies for the mistake but you know
the coaching is working for both of you
hammer on your end benji
and for nemsco and for blitzstream i
mean clearly it's working everybody was
so
excited to see the progress you two are
making so i think you both should be
proud of yourselves
and i know your coaches are proud of you
as well so uh cutie any final
thoughts no things to say you know no
mean things to say
sardosh i am going to apologize on
behalf of my boyfriend ludwig who keeps
calling you sardoush
you are not a douche i want you to know
that you're very sweet and you're good
at chess
thanks let's go and beat ludwig so he
can stop calling you that
whoa you got to put him in the place
sometimes
clearly i've chosen your favorites here
and benji actually cutie
was betting money on you so yeah i won
ten dollars on you benji thank you very
much
no worries i got you all right you two
have a good one thanks for joining us
thank you all right wow that was
really wholesome i mean i kind of feel
really badly for
sardosh right now he seems despondent
he's
just crushed by those games and he had
that second game he was just right there
away from checkmate he was so close
and blundered the queen at the end so
that 2-0 score
not represented how this match was it
was really close
should have been one to one just at the
finish line there and benji
he sees the tactics when he needs them
and is able to win the match 2-0
it was good it was good game it was a
tough game i'm excited to
i'm excited to keep watching both of
them and we
will see them in the championship racket
we don't know yet who they will play but
we know that benji fishy is the top seed
out of that group
he gets a couple extra thousand dollars
for winning the group and for sardosh
he's
upset he'll bounce back he's playing
great chess
that result to me you know as somebody
who coaches it's
something that you can ignore as a coach
and say no the way you played
was excellent and i hope that he just
continues the push
because he's already strong player and
we'll just get stronger and
there's another fun event after hog
champs there is
the twitch rivals hand in brain march
2nd 1pm pacific time you don't want to
tune in
on twitch.tv twitch rivals going to be
many
of your favorite streamers taking part
in what is going to be a fantastic event
and cutie tomorrow we have some great
matchups that we've highlighted before
any predictions for those uh pokemane
will win
everything um anything she touches will
equal a w
i think rain and logic i think
rain will take it um and xqc
i think xqc will take us his uh
1 40 p.m match against daniel negroni
who has won both of his matches thus far
so he i mostly said that because i
couldn't pronounce daniel's last name
the honesty is appreciated well daniel
has won both matches thus far
xqc is won his only match played against
rubius
so we'll see if x2cc can take down
the leader of that group and pokeyman
and ecstasy will end the day
facing off against one another in the
postpo match
it has been a real fun time i mean i had
a great time commenting with you i don't
know
i had a great time i will never be
invited back but we were
we were happy to be here i'm glad i
think you
will be invited back your regular chess
streams are highly enjoyable so yeah
well thank you
your spot on the commentary
it was nice to be here it was nice to
see you guys it was nice hanging out
chat
you guys you guys are doing great you
guys have gotten nicer i have nothing to
talk to you about today no lectures
um i appreciate your growth chess chat
all right well i guess i have some
things to lecture about chess related
but that's oh [ __ ]
another time another thing and arena
kings will begin
at 4 pm pacific that's in 25 minutes
from now
and hikara will be playing and you will
want to tune into his stream
gm hikaru obviously one of the best
chess players on the planet an amazing
streamer
so he will be playing in that event and
then in a couple hours from now i will
continue my just crazy day of chess
commentary i will be
covering the corporate chess
championships the world's
different corporations a lot of chess to
be had a lot of things to learn and
beauty i mean those are my final
thoughts i'll hand you over
i'll hand it over to you the sign off
here um well thanks everyone for coming
out we'll see you tomorrow with some
more
matches and four o'clock arena keens
very very excited
um yeah if you guys ever want to watch
me play chess poorly i play
every tuesday and thursday at 8pm i
not not poorly you're playing well i
have definitely
support you there and just remind
everybody as well that
you know this is an event raising money
for various charities of the players
choices so
if you can if you're able to please uh
do donate it goes to a great cause and
that note this is the end of today's
coverage of
politicians three presented by grip six
we'll see you soon
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
ripple
[Music]
ricky there is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you